oh hey everybody
6:00 a.m. people are starting to wake up
here in sunny California
whoa just realized our background is a
giant eye
yikes cool that's pretty cool
what you got planned for today Nick 6
a.m. oh man you're gonna we're gonna be
here a little bit longer and then you're
gonna go do we're getting breakfast
immediately after this okay
yep well breakfast need sustenance and
watch the next people we are gonna watch
the next play on the stream people do it
we're gonna definitely tune into that
we're gonna keep that going yep
hi Korea hey how's it going Korea wow
it's Conan sleeping in the bathroom I
don't believe so I think he's he's
probably home but we don't know he could
be he's everywhere yeah you never you
turn the corner he's right around back
hi everybody again if you uh if you're
just clicking back onto us
we dislike oh through the the streams
there so we may have lost you so hello
hello you got to start this one on ok
all right so plants vs. zombies - we're
learning together here
let's this is interesting
ok all right it's loading up
would you like to play through the
fundamentals no or yes I think we died
right in Wow okay do we ever yeah yeah
they don't necessarily live your life
let's do it hey Penn applix house bleh
all right okay so there's a lawn looks
like we probably have to mow the lawn
somehow okay we got a son another son oh
wait a minute okay so we don't want to
so maybe we can use the lot away yeah
okay okay okay do that here we go here
we go chance Nick help me out here what
am I doing wrong
wait I can pause maybe we go back maybe
we do the tutorial let's do we got we
were all community we're a little yeah
overconfident they're overconfident we
did so well in Mario I just think we
yeah we we got a little excited there so
we apologize we're gonna learn how to do
this go back yeah for those of you just
joining us my name is r.j. my name is
Nick this is Nick hello
we both are Conan staffers and we're
about to play plants vs. zombies
RJ why don't you remind the chat what
you do at the show I work at Kona Co
which is Conan's development company and
sorry I don't know how to get exit to
the menu we show you a level exit level
okay oh that's right
well figure it out we're gonna figure it
out we're gonna figure it out sorry
about the delay
everyone okay here we go let's think
all right we're at Ben Affleck's house
Dave for their sons that we can collect
there's little plant oh okay oh wait
that guy can shoot okay okay okay I need
more sons to get okay just look I'm
putting him here yeah and he'll shoot
that here we go
but wait he's not how many times does it
take to kill a zombie I think I should
have put him farther back we need more
sons all right I'm gonna put him here oh
okay that one we got okay
okay we're getting in here we're getting
we're getting a hang of it all right
this is your game
I keep freaking we could be watching it
on this screen someone asked Nick what
is the hardest task you've had to
accomplish and how did you do it just
ever in life Wow
I think they mean in Conan but I want to
ask you in life what's the hardest thing
you've ever had to do
Wow that is - can I put - do you know
the answer to your like if I ask you
that would you just have an answer ready
for that yeah trying to figure out what
time it was in Germany early yeah it was
the hardest thing ever
learning plants vs. zombies - is that
not the easiest thing I'll say that when
do we get to use these lawnmowers is my
question I don't think you do is there
for show they're just teasing me they
might be gosh this reminds me of a game
where it was a I was like an airport
game and you need to be the air traffic
controller more than your plane's kept
going you had to direct them - okay yeah
and directly that moment that you just
called like an airport something Airport
I think I was the only one to download
that game but it was fun
someone said lawnmowers or a last resort
so maybe that's oh okay let's look your
last
oh wait there's other stuff now that has
been unlocked that I can use what do you
think this is this little guy and this
little guy
I'm gonna try to use this one I'm gonna
throw him right there I don't know what
he does maybe just like a shield oh
[Music]
there you go hi from Egypt Wow
being Keaton what was it I don't know
there's a bit good yeah I think it's a
pit he's eating my god I don't know if
that's a good thing I think it's good
cuz he's not you don't want to get to
you right so he's blocking and I put
another guy okay I got a coin it's all
about the coins
maybe it's Michael Michaels I don't we
don't wave oh no there's a million of
them are you doing anything to make them
shoot or they just don't know no they're
just shooting well I don't know if this
flower is my phone right there and put
another one of these guys here son hey
guys good morning 6 a.m. 6 10 year in LA
Oh hot sauce
ooh who is that
hey neighbor this is Ben Affleck this is
his house it's just like the hot sauce
yeah I gotta give him the hot sauce yes
you can
going once a person taco Oh
crazy Dave of course crazy Dave guys I
want to get back to fighting natasha
cruder midnight in Australia is
officially there's been a lot whoa all
right
the Oh lemon bye see ya here something
was just from Egypt now we're in ancient
Egypt savage bullet is also from
Australia
what's up Australia is one of them along
that's one place I would go to frog I
need to go there I'm not been Australian
looks like I have it on the list I
really wanna go nostril the birds you go
Sydney I guess you started Sydney right
I think it's just what you do and then
you'd met the adventure out right where
should I go if I visit Australia Savage
Bowl let's get questions do you want to
try I guess yes give it a try oh okay so
we have a tip from Jed tang he says you
should put the sunflower in the back
okay I think then I think he's starting
about like behind no no behind the okay
zombies they go
I think Zoey you mean hi from India hey
that's awesome
what's going on
it's kind of relaxing music it's
sunflowers a lot of people are talking
about these sunflower right here where
do I put it there behind the zombies
back here yes oh wait I did get him Oh
sunflowers in front of the lawnmower I
definitely didn't do that yeah you don't
want this don't Somme bees like meat or
plants frog the critter hello from the
Czech Republic
hey how's it going welcome I think this
guy's gonna get me for sure the guy on
the top you need to add more guys oh
[Music]
you're just called noobs I can't imagine
that's a good the ultimate insult live
in noobs truly in is the proper way to
spell noob with zeros in the middle like
n00b are you calling you how think I
called us anew I think so I think I'm
calling him a noob for spelling noobs
wrong Wow
oh there it is with a Z there we go the
CI mr. Bruno's you're gonna insult us
please please do it Rafi I'm gonna be
completely honest I have no clue what
I'm doing I have no idea great I no idea
if it's working it is we're not we're
still playing but all I'm doing is just
putting them everywhere I can I mean
yeah like well I have to imagine you
know as we continue there were more
nice and this will get more difficult
get crazier yes I mean that's great
succeeding someone said the entire first
row should be sunflowers you know we
should plug the tutorial it's su ly we
skipped it and now we're regretting it
but I'm kind of proud of us wait a huge
wave of zombies is approaching I'm
pretty relaxed they calm down doing
great
get out of Sun you're out of money oh I
didn't realize later second week
oh boy there we go Kenneth Kenneth J
Richardson said you're doing great
Thank You Kenneth J Richardson oh good
just I think I just beat that little all
right well we got a map or something
yeah everybody all right guys the golden
creative boy says why aren't you
answering us what what did you ask I
missed your question good news we found
a map to his tacos okay ancient Egypt
[Music]
what's the upgrade to get the cherry
bombs
Joshua shoe everybody Josh what do you
see anything that's a change yeah I know
I didn't but we'll do it
Natasha cruder to what let's to know
what's our favorite decade of music I
think it's easily the eighties where's
yours says the guy in the jean jacket
the eighties just think about what the
80s gave us musically alright Phil
Collins okay musicians of our time was
Genesis the eighties - yeah that's Phil
yeah you know I know I didn't know if he
was that was the 70s or not no I think
what people Peter Gabriel was they I
think was Genesis before in 70s and then
in today ATZ was Phil you know what I'm
gonna I'm gonna go out on a limb and say
maybe the 90s interesting okay all right
the 90s gave us some great jams
big smokes wants to know what is your
favorite superhero movie so far I'm
gonna change my answer though I'm gonna
go back to I'm gonna go 5050 favorite oh
yeah okay any kind of like like you know
like Johnny be good like Chuck Berry any
time I'm getting Chuck Berry oh man
Natasha Krueger straight up laughing at
me for my good cause I don't think
that's what's good okay use plain food
to make these so favorite superhero
movies big smokes wants to know we're
just superhero in general I think I know
my favorite superheroes Superman what
about you who's yours I think I gotta go
Batman I think I gotta go probably the
first Tim Burton Batman Michael Keaton
Michael Mongi you says Phil Collins is
the worst musician I think it's a little
strong Michael I think it's a little
strong I don't know if we needed to go
there the seventies rock better than 80s
listen I like I like all music let's be
honest
plant got eaten try again okay where you
did this tutorial now now we're doing
this tutorial
no I don't think so yeah on level 3 we
decided to learn but Oh drag the plant
food on to the plan use plant for you to
take out now defeat the bucket in Bill
Collins is a great percussionist I agree
wait who's your favorite superhero
dependent it's Batman no it has to be I
think he's why he's just he doesn't even
have any powers them yeah but that's
kind of his appeal right like he's a
Superman can do anything
what's that what's that sounds awesome
there's no stakes for Superman encrypted
okay there have you ever seen Superman
there's some one thing that will mess up
Superman if he knows it just avoid that
one thing and he's fine
all right here we go
here we go so was it nice you beat the
tutorial on the second try good shot
thank you good thank you very much all
right let's see wait so we said Superman
has no personality I take offense of it
he's wrong I mean he's very he's a dry a
dryer cap he's kind of a no BS
dr. Manhattan that's uh from Watchmen
right is it so we just mentioned dr.
Mann I think so I think I think that's
that's watching
read Blackmore says do you read the
YouTube chat yes we do are you confirmed
you just yep confirmed from them as
these zombies are moaning we keep
forgetting the we keep forgetting me uh
we keep forgetting the sunflowers and
Natasha's giving us a heads up to get
the sunflowers Natasha where do we put
the sunflowers wait the more sunflowers
the more money oh I see so the
sunflowers generate the Sun to come down
I know it's not science but in the game
it works I think that's what she's
saying because then we can get more
points more money to buy them okay the
different items love you Shane wants to
know when does this marathon finish it
finishes at noon news every time which
is six out a little under six hours away
okay
zombie man we got another news guys it's
starting to be hurtfulness okay it's
starting to be a little hurtful then I
like it's fine
the nude the noobs all right Natasha
gave us a thumbs up we're okay it's the
sunflower you did it random more
sunflowers than more money
[Music]
what struggling to comprehend the basics
of a children's final wave somebody said
to place the potatoes in the front
all those are potatoes we thought they
were like apples and cores okay I got a
peach pit here's a peach pit oh yeah
there we go
it blocks them oh they get stops and
they've started eating it I see I see
how it works
oh yeah but then I feel kind of bad for
the potato he's our buddy
he's sacrificing ourselves the game the
mission well there walnuts somebody said
I guess could be I don't think it's a
potato potato doesn't seem right potato
yeah I thought they were almond they
look I I'll buy walnuts
you're a lot of plant vs. zombies
experts there really are it was the last
one it's the last not me right yeah
finishing off air
God was waiting for that we've been
powerup oh yeah more coins the cabbage
Pulte roll cabbages over obstacles at
the enemy that seems useful okay okay
good we also have a new quest available
we do that new quest yeah now we have to
finish this stream yes death and I said
he played this game all the way he or
she to the end of the the whole game you
meet the whole thing seems like there's
a lot more than even close to them how
did you beat this whole thing
check out the travel log okay unlock
bloomerang I think we do it nicely we're
gonna do it we're gonna do it
I said Conan is our father now he's not
I would be a good dad Nick another
serious question dogs or cats
I gotta go dogs definitely gets dogs is
the is the answer then I can't stand
cats sorry I'm sorry too a lot lovers
out I cannot stand your silly internet
that you don't like cats they're sneaky
oh my gosh they I when I was little my
cousins used to have one I always
thought it was like following me and
like I know not a cat guy I know people
love cats the cats are cute I'll give
you that cats are cute but dogs you
didn't like take Heike I've never seen
someone taken cats not hiking no way I'd
spend the coins on more things get rough
stock up on big smokes I'm not a
disgrace
I just prefer dogs more of a dog guy
[Music]
okay here's the okay so look there's
wacom obstacles yeah that's what they
call them in the game okay I should
spare obstacles and then this new green
thing that we have can toss over
obstacles remember oh so I think that's
why I see so you didn't place those
obstacles you're not putting those two
blonds those were that Rekha those are
already there
they probably helped right but can they
go through it how do they get rounded
[Music]
I'm gonna try I'm gonna try to place one
I don't know how far they can throw
though that's the problem
oh that far I guess as far as you need
this game is getting difficult more
difficult
what are you breaking yeah that's
actually breaking the that one obstacle
is that good I think so I mean I think
there's the last knob you know you said
if you don't take the sun's they turn
red and then power of the zombies oh
okay
if we power them appalling but like if
they move faster oh there you go
what'd you just do what is that it's the
machine gun thing are you guys reading
this yes we are love you said we are
yeah yeah sunflowers first always people
are really really driving on the
sunflower thing really I guess you just
get more money making more sunflowers do
that more why you so look you can't you
run out of is that does that cost money
juice it's this stuff
the wave of zombies is approaching what
you need more shooters buckle up you
need one more shooter out there actually
need more than whoa
yeah you need more whoa mine throw
everything you got add just just this is
crazy oh oh this is not good
we need more before shooters there you
go that's good Oh eternal day drug are
they accepting advice yes please give us
advice on how to play this game we need
more we need more of that money
come on red meats are almost dead though
right no this is good yeah great
that was that was too close I was good I
mean you did it somehow I don't know how
I didn't look good for a second there it
looked like you were definitely failing
but I think we're moving on okay good
[Music]
waffle tarts wants to know do pancakes
and maple syrup jelly bellies count as
breakfast or do I have to be a real
adult right now you know you eat though
eat those jelly bellies that you do you
candy for breakfast you do you Oh big
prize the egg cracks so one thing to
fill the singularity everybody is saying
fill up the potato meter first okay give
me a lot of good advice chapter collect
always a woman it's not a potato well
not literally says mama
[Music]
jelly belly time all right here we go
next level
oh my gosh I don't keep this guy why is
this guy we got what the pot on the face
of the game I don't know and his weird
time machine car yeah
what is happening on top okay I want
it's telling me to click this
[Music]
upgrade oh look at all this stuff done
yeah
holy cow this is gonna take us three
weeks the stream is an extended 3-wood
extended so he beat this game okay see
ya so go I don't think you have to do
what he's saying I think he's just
giving you okay so good can you scroll
oh my gosh oh my gosh what and you do
the same thing the whole time
this is insane it does it has to be I
mean by the time you're at level 30 it's
gonna be oh my gosh this would take your
whole life all right well let's continue
what are we on you're on for buckle up
buckle up read blog in black more hey
what's up reading sup how's it going
where you from read read black memory
from I'm gonna guess Kansas City
alright the turbo button speeds up your
game faster so faster plants faster
zombies okay okay good you know good to
those obstacles there's twice as many
there's gonna be a problem
[Music]
I think we need more walnuts in more
strategic places yeah
wait what are the ones what's the one
with the little red blinking thing that
comes out what does that thing supposed
to be what do you mean that's the one
that's a walnut
oh it's like a bomb okay we're getting
some contribute
no something saying we can't pick the
sunflowers first what like guys we're
getting we're getting mixed signals here
from the chat
[Music]
Benson from Singapore oh you're playing
the whole thing you need to save the
leaf power for later levels wait you
don't run out of new leaf power there's
gotta be a way to get more lead the
suggest that that's the rapid fire
should have read the tutorial it's not
too long you can go back though see this
just looks like chaos like look at what
is happening on the screen right now
there's this one a zombie apocalypse is
like see this is different cuz you don't
get those you don't get the shootie guys
I see snog rod wants to know what are
the work hours like at the show oh no
didn't mean to do that geez sorry guys
well Ryan to buy $50 worth of coins I
did not mean to do it
the work hours of the show it's a tip
it's it's typical it's kind of it's it's
like 9:00 a.m. ish to 6:00 6:30 ish but
Jacob change but you see
and sometimes the work hours are 24
hours like like this stream
so there's a boomerang guy now what's he
doing
throws boomerangs oh yeah he looks like
a plant
[Music]
no it's more terrifying the zombies or
the fact that these plants and we walked
into this combat like yeah this is what
happens in the future
[Music]
all right do you play you feel like I'm
home I mean sorry you're on a roll I'm
like I'm enjoying watching you all right
la stairs as pretty sure zombies are way
worse then evolved I don't know I mean
if you saw a plant shooting boomerangs
what would you would you really be
saying that you're like we need some
zombies take care of zombies walk like
you smell away from him
yeah boom rains gonna get you Benson
Thao has school tomorrow
yeah it's a weekday school night a wife
is always asked favorite movie from the
Oscars you got one I do my favorite
movie yeah I loved I Tanya this year
okay I like a lot I tell you a lot I
love the Florida projects
those are probably my two very totally
get out was my favorite yes great
yeah it was great no gray space face
just said arts humans just evolved
plants anyway it's kind of deep but I
don't think so I don't think so at all
it's too deep for 6:30 in the morning
alright so I'm trying to do what this is
telling me to do now use the power up
[Music]
[Music]
some wonder said the worst movies are
always the nominees in the visual
effects category I'm gonna have to
disagree I mean I think it's all it's
all what you like right sir it's just
writing you know that's true
oh I'm like aiming here I'll swipe the
zombie somebody said he's oh yeah okay
okay
good-looking uh oh you can you can like
flick them too this game is getting
weird all right toss power toss great
now you can use the power rule Ellis 2 5
6 1 so did you guys see we're under 20
49 I love Blade Runner later 2014 you
know I've never seen the original and I
want to see that first I'll watch
gladiator if you watch the original
Blade Runner
alright I think that's fair we'll do
that all right here we go
great now use powers that have fun with
power-ups
[Music]
read Blackmore listen oh did we see the
venom trailer I did see that it looks
interesting it was good it could be good
[Music]
what we have the sonic like why doesn't
the Sun and the walnuts involve anymore
[Music]
[Laughter]
but I do not know what's happening
there's no indicator if there's no
points anymore
there's no yeah this game is totally
changed and we're oh wait that's good
do keep doing it it almost feels like
I'm cheating I'm not
oh wait Joshua says this is the special
mode with no sons goddamn OSE mr. broy
says it's teaching us how to use the new
power up that's what this whole thing is
about this isn't even the game another
tutorial there are more tutorials in
this game I'm extremely impressed with
the amount of knowledge as the Chad has
about this game they pull us literally
everything oh this is just to practice
emergency scenarios you won't use it
very often isn't the whole game kind of
an emergency
yeah that's true what does it make us go
to the store come on do you game oh my
gosh they got us I guess I'm buying wait
you love just spending money spending
weights have to close so we needed more
peace years I think that's it was
clearly our problem you have a favorite
plant some probably grass well I just
slice your favorite playing a nice lawn
oh my count doesn't it I guess I do like
that the smell of a nice fresh colors
now whose love and grass now you're all
on the team
all right let's go level six do you a
favor play you gotta make me man answer
the hard questions and grass how come
you know what I wish I wish if you know
how when you cut grass it has that like
fresh like super legit smell yeah I wish
that if you had like a blade of glut of
grass and you took scissors and cut it
it made that smell you know I'm saying
it probably does right just very a small
amount no like the reason we smell it is
cuz you're cutting all the grass at once
yeah but if you snip one blade of grass
where is it actually just the lawnmower
fuel than I like smelling I can't decide
it's not then we got the fuel thank you
let's do it let's rock
[Music]
m'kay Moreland says grass would look
better as a costume than all those jeans
technical difficulty Erin Blair can I
ask you something happened to the game
oh noes you know what let's switch games
let's play a little game called game was
a fighter one Oh streets streets yeah
streets of rage it's not late let's so
you guys talk for a second
all right entertain the fine folks with
your amazing pan turn well we don't have
the what's it called big smokes see you
later bye you know yeah get some sleep
[Music]
um so question did you for it to figure
out fit today yes did you pick that out
do you like lay that out next to your
bed I think I'm thinking the night
before I'm gonna wear I'm gonna wear
denim tomorrow like do you think is the
night before when you're in the mood for
denim or did you wake up this morning a
question you know I need a no this is a
really great question I mean I think
there's no wrong time to wear denim I
think it's uh it's practical it's like
it keeps me cool it keeps me warm but
not too warm okay it's like a good like
denim is a good yeah I'm all about it
for the legs when wearing denim right
should be about eggs for the rest of you
but yeah alright
but this doesn't get hot no I'm actually
quite comfortable have you ever worn so
if you ever worn a denim jacket but
buttoned up I don't think I've ever seen
anyone wear a buttoned up denim jacket I
nobody wants to see a button-up denim I
think I don't know if I'm cool enough
for that I think that takes a special
kind of cool really melts right I'm
doing it now see but not all the way up
denim is bad and really hot weather well
luckily it's actually not too hot in LA
currently so it's it kinda is nice right
now I'm gonna say it's also probably bad
wet weather that's true thing just you
definitely want to get caught in the
rain
tighten up hello from North wait could
we talk about this background right now
I just noticed that the background is
someone do karate is that is that Laura
Croft oh maybe I don't know maybe some
guys we have Streets of Rage coming up
yeah there's a classic the streets the
great age start to you too Pete
join tech listen ok sorry guys we're
setting up Streets of Rage it's gonna be
awesome it's gonna be super fun maybe
not as fun as plants vs. zombies but if
you guys could create a video game what
would it be your perfect video game the
perfect video besides denim or is 28 and
Wars just what you currently play yeah
the perfect video game to me involves
some kind of like swimming aspect
there's not many swimming game now the
[Music]
swim racer maybe like a high dive game
that's actually kind of a good idea
where you could do some cool jumps
tricks high dive splash the splash zone
is what we would call it splash down
this way zone splash zone and then oh I
got it ready it's it's a diving board
you got a cannonball off the diving
board and the point of the game is to
get as much water out of the pool as
possible and as you upgrade you get
fatter okay I come like a alright
cannonball guy and you got to jump in
someone's stealing this idea right now
by the way I know oh it's you player
yeah oh yeah we got to thank you oh I
don't want to press the bad guy soon you
press the back table so okay cool guys
Streets of Rage is happening very
excited okay this is cool
never play to get two player game like
this alright whoo
I'm gonna pick blaze blaze all right we
go Adam what color do you know I think
I'm where you want oh no I'm too player
I think okay oh you are yeah yeah okay
you are you are all right good okay I'm
gonna be blaze all right I have Adam on
this here or in the game here clear one
let's do it all right so tell me about
this game you've played this game I've
played this a while ago it's it has like
a double dragon vibe
oh you're two guys you're just beaten
I'm a girl don't worry I didn't even
realize that yeah blaze is a girl well
we just have to beat the hell out of
people every you know whoever is around
well I'm gonna why'd you wait oh the
cops are coming
oh they're shooting at someone and OH
training fire this is great here that's
it how do i punch B B punches C jumps
beats punches it's shooting more stuff
let's go
whoa okay here we go there it is well
you see that's me sorry sorry
wow I'm kicking some butt
that guy's pink hair that's cool
wait was that you know I'm the I'm in
the yellow little tank top obviously
obviously would you see that jump kick
wow this is awesome
are we the best it Streets of Rage to do
we beat do we make a record wait you
just punched me you literally threw me
over your shoulder in your mad that I
accidentally punched you I didn't mean
to
oh yeah there we go knee to the face
kind of store are we standing in front
of it's a bar oh oh breakfast diner is
really need that was a video store Oh
breakfast diner nice well you definitely
just sorry sorry sorry sorry I'm kicking
all the butt here hey god kicking oh how
do I get in one of these telephone
booths oh there's an apple you take the
Apple you are in the Apple yeah you
almost said you almost threw me over
your shoulder you you almost did yes oh
wait wait wait what are you doing wait
look at this Apple you got it yeah we'll
take yeah I need to get this bottle how
do I get the other press audio yeah
everybody rise
she's at least smacked it out of your
hands sorry sorry
are you kidding me alright a lot of
streets or age bands in the chat that's
great this is this is a people on screen
if we're older than this game it's
process we have to be I don't yeah yeah
we will yeah yeah we are yeah yeah yes
we are how old are you 43 I'm 31
okay so yeah definitely I think this
game I was I brought like six on this
about Oh release wait oh everyone saying
we should have been Axl the other guy we
wanted the other middle guy who I just
got a is that the best character as a we
should bet this peipus
Oh get a weapon what are you I'm finding
them I'm picking them up maybe look
around man um one thing you guys should
know is that Nick and I are on a
softball team and Nick where's this is
80 what are you about to say Nick is a
great shortstop
that's all I'm gonna say wow that was
nice out of nowhere letting the chat
know the skill set I like thank you RJ
plays a mean first base I got he's like
a he's like a Hoover just he gets all
come on we gotta go this way yeah this
is this the first of all oh yeah this is
like a this reminds me of contra a
little bit the the crazy spread shoot of
guns yeah do you get guns in this or no
oh this guy has a whip someone said been
pushing multiple buttons unlocks a
superpower let's try it
yes hey doesn't nothing wait it does
that wait this is the superpower I just
did it
this is shooting
I think is maybe we should wait for them
yeah should I wait I did it the wrong my
gonna get this night yes oh dude hold on
there's a hey Mon what I want that whip
where'd you get that I don't have it but
this this one has it this enemy has it
what time is it now in America it is 656
a.m. here in Los Angeles California
Mitch which means what time in New York
City Nick 9:57 in New York
second do it I've woken up early from
that oh boy presume that might have been
me I was definitely with the lady good
morning from New York good morning good
morning New York hey what's happening
yeah I think it's you nothing we gotta
go this way yeah oh wait oh sorry sorry
no no no this is it is a boss this is
the boss way I don't know do you know
your hit post the back I don't know
that's all right
wait these guys are huge yeah this is
this is a piece got off quick
it's got tough super quick stand board
play contra 3 next I will of contra 3 oh
we're trying to beat is very bad it
again yeah we're really bad cuz it like
changes in the middle of the game I'm a
pretty sure the notoriously hard game I
think I think looking like the top yeah
I mean I think he's always a top gamers
in the world at least I tell myself that
then I don't feel good now pretty sure I
think it is I think it's like I think
people know it as hard yet I think I'm
learning about you is that you think
you're one of the best viewers know on
the plan the chats like I'm going by
what the chat says like it listen I
didn't say it I'll accept it I didn't
say we got a hold on to this comment
it's gonna get me through Wednesday
whoever something was who said that
somebody said I think was Joshua said
that was great
use the grabs they stopped throwing the
boomerangs okay good question are you
still talking about the plane yeah I
think maybe they might be still talking
about the plant really loves watch out
for the boomerang guys coming back okay
do you guys Robert would rather watch
paint dry
that's fascinating oh wait are we on
level 2 we are on the next level yes
this is the music for the game I think
she's a little too happy for this area
okay it is like weirdly literally street
fighting cheerful for this street fight
that we're in I'm gonna say this game is
way easier and I think more fun than
plants vs. zombies there's a poster of
someone in a bikini on the wall can you
imagine and take yourself back to when
set to say Genesis fairs here and you
saw that in a video game that was like
cutting edge like that was looking it
was like an edgy thing to see you know
in a 16-bit did you ever have any
posters on your wall as a kid I did any
ladies you run lovely I had a Britney
Spears woman listen I didn't I did love
Britney Spears Spears but I did I have
had it like on the other side of my
shelf thinking that my mom wouldn't see
it if she didn't go into your room like
it no she did and she definitely saw it
yeah I mean yeah she was like who's that
like she didn't know Britney Spears
can Jordan give us a coffee lecture I
you know what I've heard the coffee
lectures so many times I you know I I
get what you want to hear it but I'm
telling me it's not it will be here for
hours it's you I think you I think
you're hitting me it might be this
correlation what a game this was I agree
this we're game this is we're playing it
now that is true this is now you can get
this right now to play
I'll pick up the ball I just keep eight
guys in 100 sorry sorry sorry I thought
that this Jordan play games I don't know
the answer do you mind someone else's
there's a remake of this game that's a
good question I don't know for sure I
wouldn't be surprised though I think
this is like I mean this is a pretty
popular someone says they they feel
young again because of our conversation
well that's great that's a nice thing I
think that's exactly that's why they
brought us in at 5:00 and it's like this
is what the check cause the talking time
machine Megan didn't know that we could
screw screen mobile games yeah it's it's
pretty amazing you can kind of do
anything
a lot of Jordan questions Jordan its
Jordan a nice guy is the music is still
little too oaky for my liking for this
scenario that these guys just keep what
do you think it is that we did and make
all these guys why are they great
question and like where's the police
well they're shooting fire look I mean
there's literally chaos there we go okay
that's police well I can they help out
more than just one time like I mean like
the streets are literally raging can we
get some law enforcement we are the law
enforcement dude we are like Batman
vigilantes just taking it upon herself
I'm trying to pick up this knife and
then I getting beat up
all right guys
where you got there
all right everybody it is 7:00 a.m. now
on the on the west coast here in LA and
we have another check-in from Conan
Conan O'Brien everybody okay pull
somebody here it is seven o'clock and
here's the big scoop who's inside the
Jeff doll Oh Mike Sweeney Mike Sweeney
former head writer and now the guy that
produces and runs all those travel shows
you see Mike Sweeney there he's the one
that does the travel shows fun fact
about Mike Sweeney he used to do the
warm-up for the show then we decided to
go for laughs and we replaced him but
anyway hilarious guy great head writer
and now does all the travel shows Mike
Sweeney what's up y'all it's a 24-hour
mobile marathon sponsored by Google Play
what do you think is hoodie right it's
got Tigers on it it's got other things
on I'm trying to do my best for you keep
the energy up fashion wise in the
morning let's hear it for Argentina make
Nick's head to Fatih hold down the fort
whoa man early morning shift 5 to 7
killing it by the way just bodies over
here everyone is just naps
everyone is just napping it's crazy and
these two gentlemen took it to the
streets with a lot of Rage playing
Streets of Rage as well as super Mario
run and plants vs. zombies 2 that game
is bananas I don't know who came up with
that game but it was totally cuckoo
birds and I kind of fun to watch right
now you know we promised you a bunch of
amazing things over this 24 hour stream
special guests we've had them snacks
we've eaten them costumes we've worn
them and exclusive musical performances
we got another one for you right now
it's this band Sophie Tucker there's
this amazing duo and this song is called
drinky you can only see it right here
right now on a 24-hour mobile marathon
stream let's take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
move away
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in event oh god I'm gonna go ahead and
do a bathroom that way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
Sophie Tucker with drinkie that song is
great ah I heard that song for the first
time when they played it on our show and
I haven't stopped singing it since they
recorded it like last week and it's just
when the guy comes in with it every
division I just it's crazy my brain just
goes into this fugue state and I need to
sing it all the time uh hey everybody
welcome back Red Wings 15 how's it going
I don't know that hey Kremen how's it
going
but it's sparta of eight I love it I was
just I'm not gonna bring Jordan on cuz I
had to spend a week with him in Italy
and I think that's more than any man
should have to take with Jordan zelanski
any human being but yes clap clap we all
do the clap claps ah welcome back to the
24-hour mobile marathon sponsored by
Google Play they've taken away my clock
so I can't tell you how far we got but I
can tell you how far we got to go
because we got a little countdown let's
put that up Phil put up a little
countdown where is it gonna pop up I'm
pointing to it I think it's gonna pop up
right here there it is
as promised four hours 51 minutes 54
seconds 53 seconds 52 seconds I can just
spend the rest of the time counting down
and wouldn't that be a game in itself
we're gonna play a little game called
elder scrolls legends all right here it
is right here there's a dude staring at
a girl across the fire it's already
gotten creepy I love it this guy's got
an owl on his shoulder what is happening
here this is crazy oh there's a dude
with it oh this is one of the catch
Khajiit I think they're called like cat
people that's what I like to play when I
play Skyrim or elder scrolls it's always
gonna be Skyrim to me don't try to make
me call it elder scrolls can I tell
Conan to visit Indonesia
I will come to visit Indonesia partly
because I would love to go to Indonesia
I get to go on all the travel shows I
would love to go to Indonesia who
wouldn't win a street fight me or Jordan
I will say and Jordans not here to
defend himself I think I would win
and here's why because I'm huge and
strong and I would punch through him
like a golf ball through a wet paper
plate Durin's not a fighter he's more of
a behind-the-scenes he's like you know
Littlefinger and Game of Thrones Baelish
and he's got like a cloak I swear to God
Jordan is like basically like two months
away from just wearing like a little
finger cloak and walking around like
that Sansa what should we do the game
are playing Chris a gaming channel Chris
gaming channel were playing elder
scrolls legends low-low I think you
meant to write Yolo I'm not sure Yolo
means you only live once lolo means i
don't know lisa only lives once that
seems a little mean okay what's our
avatar gonna be this is important okay I
like people who Hammerfell or Tamriel's
most talented and resourceful warriors
as a Red Guard you will more quickly
collect weapon related cards oh this is
a card game well we're learning a lot I
like this dude over here oh wait oh I
see oh wait okay I didn't understand
these are all classes all right the orcs
you know I don't like the orcs cuz I
feel like they have bad dental hygiene
they don't take care of their teeth and
that's important man you know not just
because for appearance and looks but
also like just on a bacterial level you
know you're gonna if you don't take care
of teeth you're gonna have bad breath
it's just gonna happen and nobody wants
to hang out with somebody have bad
breath so no to the orcs the Red Guard
they look pretty cool we might go back
to them what else
I'm not a big wood elf fan thanks to
your support Jed tang I appreciate that
not super into the elf's just because
you know I don't know I know this guy on
the left looks buff but they look like a
frail people now I might be a little
mean and saying that but I just kind of
feel like you know that's just my
thoughts so those are my thoughts in my
head that's how I feel about things
let's see here I'm gonna look at some
Facebook chatting hey yeah seemed lemon
Joe's it going I want to spread the love
around you know
what I do I spread love around that's
literally my job okay
orcs are gorgeous my cell you know I'm
not saying they're not gorgeous I'm just
saying they have some teeth issues
that's all I'm saying
Rock Howard - Kay this is Elder Scrolls
legends we're gonna play all right let's
get it going Arrigoni n' ooh these are
the lizard people this is kind of fun
born of the treacherous swamps of the
Black Marsh this reptilian race is known
for its natural endurance so they're
good marathon runners that's important
as an Arrigoni Anu will more quickly
collect cards that reward you for
playing a long game well that's not us
we're not gonna play this for that long
Britton this all seems like people who I
know they get together and have like
board game night know if this seems like
board game night people pass boring dark
elf so this is kind of fun the dark
elves are like elves but they don't want
to turn on the lights
they prefer I'm just not even gonna
finish that joke they prefer the
nighttime who cares they're dark elves
high elves no thanks not into that all
right Imperials these guys look kind of
cool but you know what I bet these guys
I'll talk in accents and they're super
annoying they probably know a lot about
wine you know and like like oh that ale
that comes from the whatever who cares
the Khajiit the cat people now I like
the Khajiit I have a soft spot in my
heart for people with heads of cats so I
think I'm gonna do the Khajiit and I'm
gonna do this Khajiit woman right here
oops did I already picked the guy okay I
picked him
I see the tablet just not working
actually I'm gonna do this one cuz this
Khajiit looks like she's doing yoga
which i think is important for a healthy
mind and a healthy body balance Khajiit
are quick and agile like me not like me
making them some of the most adept
thieves in tan row as a Khajiit you will
more quickly collect cards rewarding you
for nimbly attacking your opponent all
right I like that
we're doing it Khajiit cat people also
that I can name myself mr. buttons or
chief snuggle buns which i think is a
great name and that's not a name
Oh cuz we're a cat person so we don't
have strength or courage we're kind of
like jerks like a cat is this guy's got
a lot of eye shadow on all right take
the girl we did max our I don't need to
be the jacked one you know what I I
don't need to be super jacked I have a
lot of self-confidence cat boys for the
win I'm actually cat girl Madeline Sam
but you know who's counting who's paying
attention
oh goodness this looks really cut I go
second okay fine oh I didn't know
there's gonna be a card game okay a
strategy a I definitely would not have
picked a strategy game for whatever time
it is so I got a Scuttler oh no they're
already talking in accents the Coco cat
for Monster Hunter I'm not that far in
Monster Hunter oh my god I can't deal
with this voice right now man I haven't
had enough coffee please the creature in
the lane
it just means play your card you don't
need to say place your creature in the
lane come on man by the way why am I
called let's look down in the corner hey
Phil can you move me out David King
movie out of the corner to the other
corner it says Kizzy guest cuz I didn't
sign in cuz I don't want to do that but
then it says if you could see right
there it says The Forgotten hero I'm The
Forgotten hero that's so sad and I go
second Oh bummer bummer sauce alright I
hid the glowing thing oh the desperate
captain oh I've never been emotionally
hurt by a card game before but it's
average creatures okay I'm gonna tell
you know I'm not gonna attack that guy
doesn't want to die cuz I don't want to
hurt
just the other okay they both take
damage ah si s ml this is a Elder
Scrolls legends were playing lol accents
I know Kremen I can't get behind this
Steven ray seems like what I wasn't
paying attention what you were saying
sorry bro we recorded Oh pre-recorded
yes yes I'm gonna place my creature in
the lane there look it's just a
forgotten hero can you see it over there
ah the worst why do they do that to me
yeah I've played it I've played a game
before I think I understand I know if
it's hot no no thanks nope no hot coffee
for me does every single card is every
single card gonna get sassy with me this
is such a sassy game do I like the idea
of creating my own talk show on Twitch
with regular guests isn't that what this
is what are you watching right now Zen
bo7
yes i teleported i'd like to teleport
rockhard vainglory you say you know what
we might switch to vainglory let's see I
have a message or something how is it
I'm attacking this dude who straight up
oh really is that how you play a game is
that how is that how games work oh my
god alright
[Music]
you know what somebody had to write all
these things by the way I just love the
idea of like relax like a girl at her
desk like oh my god I just want to go
home like after like 50 more lines about
mead and blood savage I am a fan of
valve games yes but you know what I
never played wasn't it's a half-life of
valve game I'm never played half-life I
know I'm a loser play heavy battle axe
tell you have you bet you're making me
play a thing oh this is that still the
part of the game where they make you do
stuff oh I see
now I've made my Scuttler wait crazier
the cards are super violent Donny I
agree Oh Steven ray I used to as a camp
counselor teach a Magic the Gathering
class that's how nerdy I am I had an
awesome blue-white deck much like my
sweatshirt currently and I didn't do so
well actually the campers really kicked
my ass tab Z NYC I don't think I will
good to see you again too sicko 11:15
here we go
attack with my creatures okay boom oh
damn
oh my god my creatures all got killed oh
my god Liam ambient I think it's ambien
I don't think it's ambient ambient is a
kind of noise an ambien is a drug so I
know I don't need either it's not
that's right asteroid thank you for
stating a lot of obvious things the blue
suit man let's not Oregon Trail I've
never played Oregon Trail maybe I shall
the blue white Dan's game that's right
I'm Joseph Charles I've never played
Roger Wilco but I have played Sierra
games what's the serie game I would have
just played I think I just I am a fan of
Sierra games there they did a lot of old
school like King's Quest and stuffed and
they do they didn't where in the world
is Carmen Sandiego right I like that
game ah a foraging mud crab that's
basically me in college was a forging
mud crab after three drinks just like
crawling home I loved we'd love to go to
India Adid yet it'd be awesome Reed
Blackmore I really do want to play flip
me we might sweat to swish the flipping
legend here if I can't get past these
accent situations how am I gonna finish
your advice what's the point of having
cards if you could just attack the guy
directly I don't understand how this
works all right we did it you did
everybody
I haven't played flipping legend yet
maybe I said I love flipping legend that
game is so fun I play that game forever
hmm and I think I just might all right
me Z no easy no I have it I've been
awake all right ama do you get a shout
out there you go we leveled up I think
we should let's go full screen real fast
I think we should play that look a
couple of people in the chat and ask for
flippin legend that's like asking me can
you can you can you dance do your half I
don't know do your happy answer
something I love flippin legend I would
really like to play it just because it's
got a great Jam and I could use it it's
very early in the morning so let's do it
it's a great game for anybody who has
never played flippin legend first of all
you have never lived second of all
you've never lived third of all it's an
amazing game very easy to pick up very
easy to play super addictive one of my
favourite games in the Google Play Store
listed its beast right away it's amazing
it tells you how to play it's just a
bunch of jumping back and forth I've
only gotten to level three I think we
can do better it's 7:20 in the morning
Conan's probably asleep at his house
Florence blerg and I've had I've only
honestly had three coffees and I had a
90 minute nap it's night man it's night
man coming out here we go all right I'm
gonna play I Nora I've played the ninja
I've played the Archer I've never played
the Warlock that's who we're gonna play
right now
I guess what you pick him and then it
gets 3d that's right
prepare yourself for flippin legend this
game is amazing she's gonna be flipping
and flapping this game is awesome
and it's just an old man with a staff
just kicking everybody's ass yeah I'm
doing it I'm doing it you're gonna let
me go or what we got it we got it we got
an issue here
Oh it's teaching me how to play right
all right good
let me flip bro get off my junk and let
me let a man flip listen to that bass
we're just flipping our buns off over
here whoo oh oh but I'm in the spikes
sanic pay attention here we go exactly
gamey ghost oh man here we go here we go
I also like the idea of just being an
old man with a staff just like running
around just kicking these
whippersnappers in the bud darn it hey
when I get on the long no we're putting
it together guys look at this
look at us flipping they're gonna talk
about us because we're gonna be legends
cuz we're so good at blimp until they
flip and legends here we go the thing
though I hate being off the thing I
gotta kill a guy quick oh my god here we
go now we're in the graveyard
it's getting crazy and now we got ghosts
after us I can't slow down guys we have
to keep quit they we're flipping for our
lives now that's just where we are we've
chosen this life the blinking light
that's where we're at
I'm sorry I can't look at the chat
because I'm too busy flipping kicking
all these pools the club
my god this music is so dope
oh god oh no
oh gosh and it's creepy there we go
oh no damn it oh we did good though that
time love the sweater thank you frames
art I literally have shorts that match
it that I was wearing and everyone
looked at me in horror and said take
them off and so I did so sorry but they
do have shorts
I have Fleur get splinters coating me
I'm off the thing I hate being off the
thing hey [ __ ] wants our car how's it
going Joseph Charles plot it says junk
drawer okay now I'm gonna let you in a
little secret that I learned after a lot
of hard work a plane clipping legend
after you get like three times to a
certain level you then get to just skip
to that level I know what's going on
this little fairy you get to skip to
that level so I need to get to the
graveyard a couple more times and then
we could just start the graveyard
because honestly the graveyard has the
coolest music I'm just gonna put points
coins coins coins you know who needs a
Dark Souls who needs like another hard
this game is hard enough man oh now
we're gonna do it oh here we go
my favorite when that organ kicks in
there ain't nothing better in the
universe
[Music]
that's a shield we got a shield going
for us I gotta I gotta be careful I got
it careful there we go we're putting it
together guys ah damn sometimes you know
my thumbs have a mind of their own which
is weird because you should have mine
thumbs why did I make I died for the
mind thumb joke that was the dumbest
thing I've ever done
heck yeah that's scent the scent is dumb
thank you goblin library I'm trying to
live my fashion dreams do you want to
know something else
you guys keep pushing me here to see the
shirt that's underneath this and nobody
wants to see that shirt don't make me
take off my hoodie this is a crazy shirt
underneath here I'll do it too I'll do
it don't even don't you dare
oh my god I don't even know what I just
did I might have hit I might have I want
to just ruin my chances for getting back
to the graveyard but you know what I
don't care I was so angry when you make
fun of my fashion choices which
admittedly are core at every turn okay
you know what I've managed to avoid
every single dude so that's cool wow
this is amazing
I'm doing like a speedrun what's the
opposite of a speedrun where you just do
the worst thing and then you kill
yourself what's that called a sad run
okay that's what I just did a sadness
run challenge complete Oh baby
yeah 500 gold all right how does that
help me give me that portal man I don't
care about Oh all right yes
thank get that gold I'm making money
moves who said that who sings that song
Rihanna no it's somebody else Taylor
Swift I don't know what are the kids
doing these days making the bunny moves
I think it's like Billy Ray Cyrus I
don't know probably wrote it all right
here we go okay that guy I'm actually
guys trying to pay attention to where
I'm lifting because the last one was so
terrible here we go also I think it's
important to note I'm an idiot
aside from noting that I'm an idiot it's
important that you need to keep knocking
the guys down that's how you reset the
timer in this I found a chest watching
ID to open it nope don't care all right
Aaron must have dying inside it's a slow
walk it's called an errand unable to
follow through that's true
Oh cardi B is the person yes take off
the hoodie don't cierra no I'm not gonna
take it you know I'm not gonna take it
off for another I'll take it off in 15
minutes how about that because no one
should see more than 15 minutes of the
shirt that's underneath my hoodie I'm
just gonna put that right out there you
know what I think it's time to get the
flipping zone hood up I need to focus I
can't have these bright lights in my
eyes I gotta focus also no the hoodie is
I just also wanted you I originally just
put it up so you can see that the whole
hood it's like this - okay here we go
do it time to flip its flipping time
guys know if it's not it's not flipping
time hood goes back down that was a
terrible idea I don't know I did that I
just I couldn't see it was a mess if I
don't make it to the cave the chat does
pick up when I die that's true Shane
Baxter you're the best Ahmed thank you
Dolly's gonna stick her off the
undressing uh I think I promised way
more that I'm able to oh this is tricky
this is tricky but I'm up for it okay
we're back in we're back in I know I
should be paying attention to color the
squares which is probably the whole
point of this game but I'm not good at
this game so joke's on you life there we
go oh it's picking up you know why we're
getting close to the graveyard you ready
for that sin bring in the sin here comes
the drop right the kids say the drop
comes that car DB drop here we go okay
gotta pay attention careful careful
careful careful here we go hit the sip
let's go where's the sin row
[Music]
yo flip and legend the help it's
ridiculous I don't care about these
chests I care about flippin legend my
staff gotta kick everybody clutter and
here we go
I gotta make it there man I just need
that sweet shift in my life you know
look before you leave idiot I know the
game was sad that it totally screwed me
out of the cent and I can feel the synth
wanting to come in and be a part of this
game I can feel it yes I'll see it now
it hooked me up before see we in this
game have a shared under that's a snake
that was bad I got poisoned somehow
there's new horrors miss best
okay I got scared by the ghost I feel
like it's time I'm poor ttle I've been
to this thing a thousand times yes
Oh five times I don't like the portal
guys here we go let's just jump back
into that portal straight into the synth
let's do it now see this game it's gonna
get way crazier Oh guys I'm having a
flippin time of my flippin life whoo
baby no snakes look at me just ruin this
game
oops it ruined me okay game ruined me I
should stop talking smack about this
game rodeo clown we're doing this bear
that's sponsored by google play and
we're having a great time it's fantastic
and I'm not gonna lie to you guys one of
the reasons when I want to do this
stream was so I could just have an
excuse to eat pizza cuz I'm burning so
many calories being up for so long not
true but look I really get speed Peet's
anymore so let me have that okay just
let me have my pizza
here we go oh my god this is just your
carnage an 8-bit form this is even 8-bit
this is like Corbin this is like huffing
[Music]
that's the least scary who I've ever
heard of my life bTW that timer's going
down real fast
[Music]
having a great game why would I see it
I'm fixing myself oh oh we're in the
cave we're in the cave we got lava
we got cave dudes we got hope they're
throwing boulders doesn't matter that it
doesn't matter the old man with the
staff that's right oh boy this is smack
smack smack just these guys here we go
what do you got next what's next huh
that's all you got come on flippin
legend oh my god
that's okay okay there we go we made it
to the cave I'm feeling pretty good
we're tagging other people in Eric I
take a nap and I can't transition what
do you mean transition properly from man
to woman or from graveyard to cave
that's the question there we go we're in
trap adventure - I've never played at
Offutt but we might robert however field
what do you doubt you love to have this
job you know you see that but then you
find yourself playing flippin alleged it
like 5:00 in the morning or whatever
time it is and you kind of reconsider
your life choices I'm not gonna lie to
you
theater we all need a break
[Music]
I just can't quit these beautiful since
you know
[Music]
Pizza for the win always
who's winning the match well mone I'm
not gonna lie to you flippin legend
who's winning oh look at this
well well well you know what I could use
as a shield oh I would love a shield
give me that shield how do I get the
shield can I just buy the shield starti
trow the shield yes please
can i buy that or there we go
an excellent choice well thank you wait
what is this thing here carry two
shields and what is this thing
smashing I don't care about that I don't
care about colleen's throw weapons and
increase life game yes that seems good
no I'm not gonna right I mean it's
flippin legend you have the yeah I'd
like oh I have that already okay cool
all right great you know what now armed
with our extra I'll look at this dude I
think there's lizard people coming up
I'm pretty sure not on the stream but in
flippin legend
we couldn't [ __ ] any lizard people
because they don't exist and B they all
live underground and we don't want to
pay for their transport
yeah you gotta rent like a digging
machine it's a whole thing man it's a
mess
and then I got poison then you got to
put all that dirt back after their
appearance trust me
it's just not worth it for our budget
oh this is great no I'm gonna stop
saying I've having a great run because
every time I do that I get killed what
I'm having a great run
okay okay okay that lava man Andrew I
took a 90-minute nap we betrayed enough
flipping legend Musa ball hey Tyler
Bregenz alright Joseph just says
Ovaltine I'm never talking about a team
shaped like an oval or the drink I have
had a lot of uh dental surgery done and
you learn to drink through a straw
pretty quickly like drinking milkshakes
[Music]
oh I'm really avoiding all these guys
I'm supposed to be killing so that's
going well perfect got a new heart
Buechele also there seemed to be more
shields which is good
[Music]
I just owning you guys and throwing
rocks at me come on
[Music]
Wow bro
blade can I give you my account you've
maxed out the Warlock oh my god - that's
awesome
what happens say about what happens when
you max out a wart like white away it's
that this kind of does something give
you some Castlevania now that you
mention it I missed the gold poison
spikes this is not a good run
[Music]
I don't know that the ghosts are ever
gonna hit me I seem to be my worst enemy
in philippi legend about who lie to you
guys
pretty gnarly alright guys seven minutes
until this comes off and you see
possibly the greatest / worst t-shirt
ever made hope you're ready I'm excited
to show it to you I'm excited for the
chat too everyone leave the chat because
my terrible t-shirt
[Music]
wait this isn't fair
[Music]
how could there be two spikes on either
side
your body's ready but is your mind sir
robust all is your mind high radiant hey
jm2 MTL spoiler I'm wearing a team coach
it's not a team cocoa shirt good guess
though see if you guys could guess
what's on my shirt I think nobody can
guess it's on my shirt
[Music]
no way
I will though say I've worn this shirts
actually I've never worn a string before
so I guess you've never seen it
lucky you
[Music]
if I reach the cave five times do I get
to go back to the cave survive
[Music]
how great is this music I know kidding
want to just download the music play
in my life damn bro come on we gotta
hook me up with it
you know watch the summer breakfast all
through the afternoon when I came back
and watched it after dinner well thank
you for watching so much this drink
how's it been so far those of you in the
chat raise your hands if you watch more
than six hours into this strange and
ironic phrase do I keep track of what
shirts I do weirdly Gabe Ben I'm gonna
try to finish it I I don't know how long
is this game so doc how long is this
game animal on the shirt people are
gassing galaxy cat no way Paul Simon no
banana no Larry Smith instantly addicted
to flipping legend this game is so great
raise his hand everybody's raising their
hand yes I love it we've got a lot of
Twitter's been watching don't raise your
hand shamefully raise your head proudly
thank you for joining us for that log
that's awesome
y'all are amazing and it makes me feel
good that we've been doing this and it's
not all for nothing so thank you guys
are making us feel good
you know it doesn't feel good all these
ghouls who I'm stopping with my old man
cane I guess it's like a wizard cane
spoiler alert this is how Gandalf fights
all the works from Lord of the Rings
used bounces on their heads Oh Charlotte
pest you know it's funny as I follow
this girl on instagram i named koto
she's a singer
live from canada and lives in the UK and
every monday she goes to a club to play
trivia and ian mckellen runs the runs
the game and she doesn't into the story
of Gandalf saying trivia stuff isn't
that cool I desperately desperately want
to go there and do trivia with Gandalf
and know before you ask it's not just
like Lord of the Rings trivia it's like
it's like a usual trivia night but he
just does
[Music]
how we're out oh wait how was I supposed
to do that oh I guess I could have
jumped back right idiot
yes cavern five times
we did it guys we're making progress I
look like a nerd trying to be a douche
wrong I'm a douche trying to be a nerd
gotcha
take it flip it on its head rock boy I'm
reading your comments oh by the way I am
old so that's not a cut-down you just
stated the fact I'm an old
[Music]
here we go
wait I thought it was gonna start in the
cavern why did I start in the graveyard
darn it
[Music]
ouch
[Music]
oh that sucks
wait can I start in the camera did I
miss the time where I was allowed to
start Nick oh no I missed the portal
guys I'm so sorry that's a mess well you
know what now hopefully I can go back
and just feel good about the fact I'm
gonna beat all these guys here we go
[Music]
you know what I guess even if you jump
super quickly on spikes they still hurt
you you've never watched Lord of the
Rings The Hobbit or start well hobby
you're not missing much I'm not gonna
lie this sucked
you could there's options we're
expensive no I don't want to I want to
start with the cavern man oh oh here it
is it's right here got it alright here
we go we got even okay guys the cavern
is is this is not for the weak part you
know not for the faint of heart it's
mentally taxing I'm just gonna put it
out there because I have kind of a small
brain so just pressing back and for the
screen can be mentally taxing for
someone like me
[Music]
flower gold in these caverns a lot more
dudes throwing rocks they don't
appreciate you know it's like a kind of
person to don't be throwing rocks at me
[Music]
okay that hurt better what these guys
just hanging in this cavern just waiting
to throw rocks at somebody go do
something make a cave painting or like
invent the wheel or Creek fire come up
with some stupid thing about what the
stars actually are oh it's a big deer
that runs across the sky and that's why
there's light no it's a it's a planet
the moon is a satellite of our planet
and the Sun is a giant ball of gas you
dumb caveman stop throwing a rock at me
I'm sorry I'm just very aggravated
[Music]
you're watching to show what are you
doing watching a show we have cavemen to
beat oh this guy oh well played hunter
is that LeBron James jumping and falling
all over it's flopping legend right does
LeBron James flop around a lot yeah
everybody's saying no that's wrong he
doesn't flop he's a great basketball
players the King has some respect
flopping legend a hashtag Blaise
spiration yeah see I'm getting myself
pumped up guys and you need to do that
when you play for the clipping legend Oh
one minute till a shirt gets revealed
one minute one minute guys just one
minute all right
what am i buying here I see a lot of
fire what is this dude
release a wave of gremlins that travels
five rows sure oh I don't have enough
gold gosh darn it why does the Warlock
have a television okay you know what
don't question it let's just go yeah I'm
you bet your bottom phone right this
camera to kick these pavement or in the
end
here we go yep yup yeah nobody's
throwing rocks no no huh where's your
call you're throwing rocks well fair
enough yeah that's right I'm gonna punch
you so hard you're gonna I don't know
die by being punched that wasn't a good
cut down you know what I don't really
have hate in my heart for these guys
they don't they don't mean you know they
just don't understand they're like oh
fired what what is deer running cross
sky you know they don't know any better
here we go I gotta time this well here
we go all right lizard people finally
that's right the people who run the
world lizard people the aliens that came
to earth thousands of years ago what if
I what if I actually believed that stuff
and I just like to start going on this
rant and I try to get everybody into
this religion I've created called the
lizard people religion we did know once
and if my sister shows up in the stream
please don't repeat this in the chat
guys I'm trusting you with the family
secret a Blair family secret we were
children we got my sister to get go a
little tiny lizard you know changes
colors that's real cute and now it's
like a spokesman for a auto parts
company because everything's ruined but
we got her a gecko and our cat kept
eating the gecko and we kept buying new
geckos and just putting them in and she
had no idea she was dumb she was like
three years old she had no now she was
older than that she was like she was
between three and 23 she didn't know and
she still doesn't know to this day and I
know the chats going crazy I'm sorry I
lied to my sister and now you guys know
something about me that I'm a bad older
brother and that I don't care really
about geckos I just care about keeping
the peace except that comes to cavemen
then I care about
complete and utter
I even know what I was talking about Oh
cuz there's lizard people that story was
cuz the lizard people a great story tell
it again Americans line just rewind the
thing I don't even remember what I said
at this point I'm so tired you know what
to make me less scared of these K people
I'm not gonna think of that as lava I'm
gonna think of his delicious pizza sauce
cuz then all I'm doing is just hopping
over so they're just making pizza you
know instead of trying to kill me with
giant rocks and lava bits just pretty
scary what do you think about it
[Music]
this is
all right lizard people let's go
ah quit saying I quit saying oh my god
this is hard
Johnny be good I started crazy that's my
secret cap
I'm always crazy alright time for the
shirt you guys ready I promise the crazy
shirt it's coming here it is you ready
for it oh what's it gonna be what's it
gonna be
it's waves everybody it's a bunch of
ways let's cut to camera three I'll
stand up and show the wave shirt uh yeah
look at this oh yeah this there you go
look at it's always I have shorts too
that matches now was it as crazy as I
was saying perhaps not but I asked you
what was the last time you saw this many
waves I want shirt all right
hey thanks Jay thank you people actually
like this shirt I have shorts I could
change you too and also that match this
because I'm dead inside and I wear
matching outfits all the time that's
really fun that's right I'm Natalie not
half worn it hot darn it waves baby
waves always the shorts oh yeah you know
what I think I put it on my Instagram
where I wore the shorts because I as I
buy anything I put it on Instagram
because that's how I was raised
it's an Instagram child I'm 13 years old
by the way that's right oh yeah you know
what thank you b100 diet let's get a
shot of the people helping us out in the
back that's right let's give it up give
up right crew David James O'Malley and
please everyone the chat tell Jason
Valle go take a nap I'm trying to get
him to take a nap and hope only through
peer pressure can we make him down never
gonna happen
to fly it to the end define to the end
that's right we've set up a very
antagonistic relationship about napping
it's pretty great you need to go
shopping with me miss pointless here's
the thing I do a lot of shopping online
so you going shopping with me is
basically just sitting
next to me my desk while I don't do work
and I shot so that's what it is and
you're welcome to sit next to me on my
desk and watch me not do work and shop
if you'd like dodge the pizza sauce
[Music]
but you know what they say the things
you own end up owning you in that case
I'm pretty owned by a lot of really bad
clothes but we got the outside hopin
that got me I wonder is this game this
game is like procedurally generated
right because it feels like random every
single time oh yeah that's right these
guys are the real MVP back there and I
was like should I give a shout-out to
Phil who also took a 12 hour
took a 12 hour thing stats booster says
take a nap
everybody say take a nap except for two
fingers is saying to no sleep for you
alright don't encourage him he'll stay
on forever
O'Malley might never sleep again it's
easier he says plus he's with young
child so he barely sleeps as it is so
really he's more comfortable being away
[Music]
actually you know what maybe O'Malley's
having a good time being awake because
it's his choice you know he's not forced
awake he's being he's choosing to stay
with so he's feeling empowered so maybe
you know what I should stop getting on
his case and let him feel a power go by
to not empower somebody ouch the worst
fantastique
do-do-do-do-do-do
do you think those other guys are
currently debating life choices because
they are watching someone play 24 hours
play mobile games no they're getting
paid I don't get paid which stinks but
because I'm heavily in debt from all my
shirt choices so it's terrible but I
work another job as a flipping Legend
pro player as you can tell pretty
excited about it see me on eleague TBS
[Music]
no that was just sad there might be room
in Conan's coffin if you wanted out a
little-known fact coming actually
doesn't sleep in a coffin he sleeps in a
bed cuz he's a normal human being like
everyone else by the way I feel like you
were sleeping in a coffin I like to
sleep on my side and I don't think the
lid would shut I'm pretty wide you know
not to brag but I have wide shoulders I
mean I guess it's just my bone structure
but you know and then you got the light
coming through
you know when the lid just closes right
like this there's that one shaft that
light is right in your eyes so I'm not a
big coffin sleeper guy so not that I've
tried it I have but I'm just saying I'd
make a really bad vampire
cool cool really happy about that super
super stoked all right listen we got to
make it to the lizard people or I gotta
stop playing this game because I can't
take these like oh I can't even now I
gotta start back here but I did get to
hear some sweet sense I have to make the
lizard people
I can't keep playing these cavern guys
they're just with their loincloths and
their rocks and their lava pits I can't
deal with them anymore guys I just can't
oh I have to start the very beginning
cool you know what back to our roots
guys back to our roots okay cool I'm
just gonna dodge everybody hope that's
alright
literally dodging every person there we
go
now helping me not helping me yeah I got
one person oh this is very bad there we
go finally alright we're back on the
right foot guys here comes the sense
[Music]
dodged a lot of ghouls this is not good
for me
great great cool killed myself awesome
yes live as always come back on after
you wake up and watch us we'll be here
if you only sleep for five hours or less
for hours actually sleep for less than
four hours then come back and see us
because we're only doing it for four
more hours
Conan's not human I think he is part
cyborg honestly I'm not gonna spend the
money I'm gonna you know we need to get
back to our roots our footing legend
roots back to basics and you know Conan
is he more man than machine nobody knows
because he more machine than man I don't
know
great can you get some sick burns I
don't know if I have any real sick burns
for you you know I need to know
everybody tell me something about
yourself
tell everyone in the chat tell me the
thing you are the most proud of in your
life and I'm gonna dish out some sick
burns on you how about that that's right
set me up set up the pins and I'll knock
them down you guys want some sick Birds
Who am I Who am I did not give you sick
Birds the last thing I want to do is not
get people sick Birds all right here we
go
by the way these coins are not to scale
that how would you even transform that
large of a gold coin I mean you would
just you'd have to have your friends and
like roll at home or something
well so you know what would really help
if this guy learned how to just walk
forward what are we doing with this
diagonal hopping this is ridiculous
just walk forward and beat people out of
the way with your staff like every other
warlock ever in the history of war
locking alright here we go
self-proclaimed child genius okay I'm
leaving that one alone what's the end of
the game Jan Hakka the name of the game
is flipping a legend oh my god dizzy
death I'm not proud
does he death be proud of yourself oh
now we're just getting sad you guys are
burning yourself this is crazy
I'm seeing a lot of self burns on here
you're proud of being yeah well that
won't last long so don't worry about
that don't be too proud of it
oh that's why the enemies are standing
there because they can't move their
money that's a good point maybe that's
why they're throwing rocks at me because
they they they they're giant gold coins
this is what happens when you put your
face shine gold points you know what new
idea maybe they're giant chocolate coins
that's how they survive because I don't
see any food in this cool cool doing a
good job dodging everybody
[Music]
so I'm really happy about my current run
of not touching anything
[Music]
oh my god Blair pull it together dude
[Music]
well I think it reset when I got into
this woman thank goodness
[Music]
okay that do work close gamers we won't
be doing worthless gamers so don't worry
about it ah does Conan actually ever
enjoy the games like clueless gamer
segments Billy Beane's yes he does
actually he he really does he starts off
hating every game with a passion and
then he ends up loving every game and
hating me with a passion so it's kind of
like the hatred just kind of floats
around and then that's a big cloud and
then it kind of just lands on me which
is fine that's what I get paid for it
it's a cathode X well oh yeah all right
there we go now Manish Kumar you wrote a
lot of things that don't understand I'm
an 11th ranked or out of 250 people in
my batch and game for 26 hours 40
minutes straight in 11th grade I think I
mean that's awesome I'm not gonna that's
a great I'm not gonna burn another nerd
you know as we burn ourselves he loved
chocolate too much that was this one
terrible problem oh boy I'm going I
can't do it I'm starting at the sense
man
yeah get in here
boys in great
[Music]
dicks
I'm gonna hear these ghost haunts in my
dreams because it just sounds like an
old creepy man saying that it doesn't
even sound like a ghost now this feels
like a bad
[Music]
son of a bastard darn it's all right
wait guys it's 8 a.m. it is 8 o'clock I
can't believe it
I cannot believe it's 8:00 in the
morning you're watching the 24 hour of
mobile marathon sponsored by Google Play
I'm wearing a shirt with a bunch of
waves on it we just played a flipping
legend we've been having all sorts of
special guest Mike Lawrence
I'm in perugia the ladies of Conan the
the men of Conan Conan himself was in
here earlier we've watched exclusive
music performances from they might be
giants and Sophie Tucker and right now
let's check in with Conan O'Brien the
man himself here he is happy 8 o'clock
and who's inside
it's Sona my assistant Sona
morphs Essien there she is right there
and look what's on the back of Sona a
cannon which I think it's a symbol of
how combative she is it's a very
combative person so he's yelling at me
she's very cannon like and so I'm not
gonna screw with you after this cuz to
be honest with you I think it just is
[ __ ] after this because inside Sona
it's just like - whoa CooCoo and then
inside let's goo goo so the person who
made these dolls clearly doesn't watch
the show that much uh-oh
and look what this is getting small this
is ridiculous this one has its lungs
haven't developed yet it's so small look
at it it's just too tiny yeah they just
ran out of I mean what would it have
killed them there's more people on the
show you can eat this Tic Tac yeah
that's my only criticism I think you did
a beautiful job I think they could've
come up with a couple of other people on
staff bleh could have been a doll
and they kind of work someone maybe
someone else from the band I think they
kind of phoned it in at the end just put
a bunch little goo Goo's in there anyway
Thank You Russia Thank You Russian fan
and I guess I'll see you at 9:00
everybody welcome back oh goodness
so listen to that oh we love our
feedback don't we ah there's a giant
robot behind me because we're gonna play
a game called war robots it's huge and
crazy and loud and fun which is exactly
what we need for the 8:00 a.m. hour I'm
wearing a shirt that has waves on it and
we're very excited because to welcome a
very special man mir dear to my heart we
went on tour together for three months
slept on a bus chocolate Oh everybody
wait to see where thank you for coming
oh my gosh thank you for coming oh
goodness how's it going
it's going great um I slept what you
didn't that's true I did sleep for 90
minutes which is just enough time to
remember what sleep feels like which is
terrible it's terrible it's pretty bad
say hello to the chat we're on Twitch
YouTube and Facebook introduce yourself
tell them what you do I'm John Coto I'm
the script coordinator at Conan and like
Aaron said been on the show for 10 or 12
years back to New York and I was one of
the people on a tour bus with Aaron
that's right we had a good time that was
crazy sleeping a little tour coughing
that was oh yes we were talking about
slimmy comments earlier and and it was
it's like I don't know if anyone's ever
signed on tour bus but it was like bit
like this it'll give you extra room yeah
there's no it's like this I'm our sound
guy on the show now or I'm not exactly
his proper title he mixes sound Dave
went slow I said I slept like his the
back of his head was here okay
or maybe not the bad guy's head maybe
was his feet who knows I don't know how
he slept but they also say sleep and
this is kind of creepy but they said
sleep feet-first because if the bus
stops on a dime yeah rather your feet
get crushed than your head yes exactly
drivers yeah and it was it was super fun
so we're gonna play a game I was gonna
play war robots are you a fan of war
robots they're like those things okay
Christine let's give it a shot
you know let's give it a shot who knows
I've never played war robots dolly Holly
did you all share the costume no no we
didn't share the costume you know I
prefer being the little spoon yes
exactly
American slang right right you know I
kind of like I like being the the knife
because I sleep just like this you know
I don't like to curl up with anyone I
like to just be like don't touch me you
know I think so I like being the knife
Fork OS like up here and get away down
here oh nice I like it all right gonna
have a nap all right
all right so here we go we got this is
gonna be interesting
we're gonna get into it though my
favorite food in the old NBC commissary
in New York was was Mexican Wednesday
gosh that was good oh man those were the
days good lord
the old NBC commissary was real small
yeah I remember being tiny I was like
the size of this room but it was cheap
it was really cheap
it was delicious that's right I don't
know how so I think we go maybe just
select the robot or go do this
oh god what is that sit I'm gonna unlock
a new slot right up we're sure unlock it
I've got plenty of all right let's not
uh lock it let's equip it we might not
have you playing this game for very long
oh here we go we're gonna equip I'm
gonna give it a spiral light there we go
perfect and I'm not sure are we gonna be
finding other robots or monster it's a
robot war yeah I so I guess it's just
other robots you're gonna be fighting
Jordan probably is still shaving at home
I feel like he grows a beard quickly he
could he's a bit of a swarthy man yeah
mm-hmm I'm gonna get a seven perfect
like the gravity it's um it's a mech key
are you a gamer mr. Kurtz every gamer
not at all I wish I was
I've been Kaymer in that my friend
growing up had a Nintendo and I would
watch him play Mario Brothers okay I
didn't at the end I be like my Chinese
like guy let's let's go ride bikes so
yeah I was always player too yeah I feel
like I always had to use over my
friend's house that the bad joystick
right there was like one that they used
it was like awesome oh so I don't know I
think this moves you around and I think
you want to do one of these okay
and then I think the other one fires oh
sweet take that robots yeah dude you're
doing you're doing really I see there we
go do I know if they are a friend or foe
I feel like the ones not shooting you
might be friends I don't know but the
ones who I go back I have never been in
a robot war so I'm not quite sure how it
goes you need to turn the tower super
j.cole fan I do think this is a fun game
and once you learn how to play it
yeah I'm not representing the game well
I'm sure these are fun
this is yes sir these these must be
other keep the spiral trust me okay okay
so oh I'd like the hit movie red sparrow
have I seen it yet I have it probably
nor will I'm not a big bird fan I don't
like birds I think they're weird trust
them I don't like the feel of feathers
no let me just keep going and I know
they've descended from dinosaurs and
dinosaurs killed however many what how
many what things they're killing
machines basically they're not robots no
that's true oh do you want that okay
great are you gonna see red Sparrow have
you seen red sparrow I don't like colors
I didn't see the extra Red October
yeah yep I never saw Blue Lagoon no to
any color doesn't have to be right yeah
my feel do birds are dinosaurs shitty
fridge likes your shirt Aaron thank you
got about two waves on a shorts that
match this by the way exactly oh so that
just looks like a romper that's so for
weddings yeah for a wedding or funerals
too you know sometimes you want to make
the proceedings everybody do my ashes
get scattered at sea
I'd love for you to wear that yeah and
they blow back on me you won't be able
to see it because it's such a busy ugly
shirt so it's sort of camouflage for
Hawaii yeah it's a
[Music]
talero Dusen my name is blade and this
is john kertel we both work for coning
also how did you wander into this if you
don't know what's going on but thank you
for coming from playing games for 24
hours that means we're playing them for
four more hours that's right you're in
the home stretch
Oh stretch I think I feel crazy you know
another way I know you Aaron is that
I've written some jingles for you yeah
that's right our Jim Blair's like a girl
I'm dangle written by dr. jump Team Coco
podcast I'm used to do it Rick by John
Curto late night first one is that late
night podcast and a lot of gun jiggles
there's one I'm sitting on that you made
before we went on to her I thought I was
gonna do a web show you made an amazing
thing we just spelled my name but it was
like the coolest song ever any of these
awesome outros and I'm just keeping it
for someone because I haven't done a web
show so I'm just keeping it for when
it's there
yeah do the vote and then you could just
be bandleader and play it just play it
live going down in a blaze of glory yeah
that's what it was blaze of glory
exactly and the thing was when it comes
to being mediocre I'm the best there is
that was my catchphrase that never goes
out of stuff no I don't think it does
because I'm always mediocre forever I
mean look at me I had not even shooting
anything I'm just wandering around this
fake city I couldn't even get the
wandering to work well I have experience
with chicken leg robots I don't want to
get into it oh here we go
I feel kind of a bird thing happening
right now okay this there's no this just
seems like we're just these are just
silly silly little killing machines
maybe this is this what the future holds
for us and warfare and I like the
architecture in the future yeah you know
what this does kind of look cool
I feel like this looks like my college
that counts like Michigan State the
coset peg dorms in Michigan to cowboy
sort of those are the freshman dorms on
the left yeah I live [ __ ] with dog oh
I shot him you think a robot would blow
up and not just sadly sink to the ground
like an old man dying of a John you're
amazing composer musician
how many issues can you play well it
depends on what you consider an
instrument oh I like where this is going
what do you mean like a like a comb with
wax paper on and I would consider that
like an instrument yeah that is an
instrument yeah any anything you can do
with a comb well The Beatles did that
and lovely Rita oh jeez yeah they did
yeah the pervert workers took her out
tried to winter
oh that's amazing
so yeah I played a cop that's great not
for my hair which is why you know why
you great hair though this this old
pumpkins rotten fast a pyramid that you
got great here no man you know what I
think we're a couple of handsome dudes
right chat Hakim I don't hate you how
can I hate you I hate myself I have no
time to hate you I spent all the time
hating myself and these other evil
robots I've got a kill streak going on
mr. John Kurt oh oh really
I think so or they've just died zero a
streak now I need to fight back um did
you cut yourself on one of the pieces of
glass I know one I think is fighting
back because I think I'm just wandering
far away from the battlefield oh here we
are at 2-2 where robots work the Fonz
so those are silos we have robot parts
here we go well robots gotta eat
something right this robots been up for
24 hours that's a good question now job
do you think that the line between
traditional and new media is blurred
that I gotta say sada bill that is the
core that is the most articulate and
thoughtful question we've had in 24 or
22 hours Beth is laughing over there so
John do you think the line between
traditional and new media is blurred I
think the fact that I don't work
on the Internet and I'm sitting here
with the co-worker of mine and we're
talking about Conan and twitch and
YouTube means that they've definitely
blurred right I'm in a blur right now
it's all because I don't I work at Jason
with all these folks but it's really
coming together
yeah it's peeking out of it Jason here's
one right here you won't take a nap take
a nap Jason that was the worst joke I've
made in 22 hours he needs to check on
three hours Rhys words like recycling in
the stream that was some of my favorite
my experiences from last night that
makes retching yellow a victory we did I
think we should switch games what do you
think okay I mean uh we basically
mastered this see I don't even think
there's a war I just think that was
robot aggression unchecked robot
aggression tip is exactly what this game
should be called I mean what kind of
games do you like let's program that an
hour of John Curtis favorite kind of
game what a game what kind of gives you
like well I was looking in the Google
Play Store I loved it and I saw my
favorite game and this is a worldwide
announcement for years I have secretly
played this game oh my god I earn
private time this is amazing
sort of like lying in bed or maybe you
know after taking a shadow my God if you
say space plan I'm gonna lose my mind
cuz Beth knows that's my favorite game
David laughing hall space yeah but it's
one of those things like you hit it from
girlfriends and you know like you do
with the video game I do that all the
time you have to if I had a girlfriend I
would do it and the final thing is that
it has scores it'll say like you've this
many times you've gotten over a hundred
thousand points this many times you've
gotten over this and it's been
collecting it for years the number of
times I've played this game is
embarrassing like it's up and to like
the tens of thousands of times I've
actually sat and engaged with it I love
this I look what is the game it's called
bejeweled blitz yeah
all right all right well we don't have
it on here so I'm gonna have to download
it and I'm gonna download it and why
don't while I'm doing bejeweled blitz
how do you feel about playing a little
game called tap tap fish I can do it I
love it tap tap fish it's a very chill
fun game do the fish Tapani I think you
chop the fish I'm gonna go on a limb and
say you're gonna tap some fish is one of
the best games yeah okay yep we have
allow all this
tap tap fish needs to make calls on your
behalf like why what are you calling the
fish I'll oh that's my favorite thing
I've never had anyone asked for my
personal information I'm happy about it
tap tap fish now this game is also
called ass it's got another name that's
way cooler than I can't think of right
now it's like a sub wasa whim or
something
but it's just we call it tap tap fish
because I think they see them they they
renamed it to tap tempo it's easier
weight based on your feedback based on
my personal I was like guys you got a
change what are you doing
is it tapping fit no that's not know you
can tell I guess you would pet a fish
you wouldn't really want it cuz I think
it's a it's a small jump from a tap to a
poke yeah so it's like poke poke fish
also the fish can get you back because
of their scales if you go the wrong way
oh that's true that's on you that's
three minutes on you here we go here we
go oh yes we got something we got a
little background here some coral good
for tap tap fish no I wasn't getting a
bejeweled blitz yeah all right I'm in
anything in the in the Blitz family
anything that there's a whole family
blitz game please press button there's a
crocodile creating life one at a time
this is so tap tap see above shirt what
is that
I'm serious I'm serious I know there's
another name their best is names
the screen and collect vitality know if
anyone's watching and wants me to skip
the tutorial oh I see I just keep that
copy that now is but you what's the
difference we put you'll Blitzen
bejeweled classic see that's a great
question
I love I think of it Tanisha just walked
in and the first thing she heard me say
was very loudly what's the difference of
your visual it's a bejeweled classic
that is one of the least nerdy things
I've ever heard you say okay I'm getting
tutored I just jump right in I think you
know what I think you could tap some
fish and none will be the wiser I agree
does anyone feel like I'm contributing
to the depletion of I think you're
helping the coral frankly all right this
baby's downloading right here thank you
thank you ninja run you know it says
this is my Valentines Day event I don't
know if that's yeah this is what I did
Valentine's Day
perfect this is I love it tap tap Fisher
bejeweled blitz just this oh yeah just
tap those yeah you have to that's it is
I look lost at sea
oh thank you it kind of does look like
my head is you know wait if I were to
put on these shorts man it's a whole
it's a whole kids it gave changes
totally get you
well blade oh that's a good that's good
well today I'd laugh harder at it but if
I do that would expend precious energy
that I have to use did not die right now
I'll tell you what's going on kick-ass
ocean wave shirt thank you Richard
rainbow is this the entire game it's
just the bishop and taps I agree oh I
feel like you've tapped the hell out of
some fish every time I hit it says ten
of something ten fish eggs this might be
just space my hand for the sea I think
this might just be sea split so space
flashes a game where you tap something
in space I think we just found space
plan for the sea which is great cuz I
love space boy
this is really now they're adding up I
have 5,000 so if I divide that by 10
I've hit this 560 times Wow which is a
record for me before I sat down I was at
0 oh I have to buy stuff whoa
so yeah so I think lonely correlate yeah
we have oh my gosh look at this why are
we dressing up the coral and not oh here
we go this is what we want a weenie
fragile staghorn coral we hold on a
second
just make sure you tank let's just read
the names of the fish blue tang no I
wish I was good at you know something I
wish I was good at it's like identifying
flora and fauna yeah that'd be great you
know to be too easy the giggle of
madness over there I think my education
started and ended with these are three
let it be Oh leaves I don't even know
that what is that poison ivy oh Jesus
that's why I keep getting poison ivy
yeah I don't know about the flitter
what is it if it has three let it be if
it has three belongs to me which one is
Oh God no I don't know has three what
did you say just now well I said leaves
of three let it be let it be yeah okay
leaves of three that leaves the three so
five type of hands is more leaves of
three it comes up made and just you put
it in your shirt you're confusing
yourself oh right
what no what about leaves of four I
think there's a Simpsons joke about that
leaves the four shut the door yeah
please go forward nothing
you kept two sticks pick up sticks I'm
gonna have to delete some stuff to get
on get our bejeweled blitz on here it's
sort of like a cutscene in bejeweled
blitz because this thing is no no
bejeweled blitz is the game we're
playing for sure jogger Tok comes on
this stream we get the game John cuto
want to play blitz blitz blitz now wild
blitz is down
loading hold on one second bejeweled
blitz I can't wait because I think it's
gonna be I can't wait to see you master
this game there we go mastered so little
leaves a for eat some more there we go
what is for leaves probably something
that can kill you pretty easily a clover
oh you know what I bet clovers are
delicious but you know if there's a for
the clover seed you eat it no does that
make you more lucky and Sasha should
press it in your journal oh you're right
on the page on which you reflect on your
day where you looked ever a four-leaf
clover that you'd ever look you taste
like burning that is one of my favorite
scents enjoys yeah but my favorite sushi
chef of all time is Ralph Wiggum you
failed English me feel English that's
unpossible I just love that joke I love
it it's I also love when he goes like my
cat my cat's breath taste that smells
like cat food
yeah it's amazing I mean it's gotta be
one of the best the best the best
characters drive for and what Kona Coast
back upstream will ask him yeah I
already know the answer though because I
know everything about Kona cos we've
been we know him too well and Conan did
a great Conan this what's the series
with authors jibber jabber yeah jibber
jabber great jibber jabber episode
that's on Team Coco with some of the
Simpson writers that he worked with
absolutely yeah
where they talk about that alright cool
so this is fun you know what I'm gonna
do I'm gonna set you up with a different
game because the Wi-Fi like I was
worried about is crapping out that's cuz
we share this space with another show ya
know it's a difference it's a whole
other situation you know I had to say
that the Conan tribute team was on
earlier in the 24 hours strange yeah and
I knew the answers and they did not how
are they winning trivia night yeah I
don't know I incepted I might have been
maybe it was the weak links the weak
lakes and the and your thing oh we got a
strong link though right here yeah we
got a strong get on again
in here you know ladies gentlemen Jason
Shlomi yeah look at this this look at
this
get on in here man get on in there good
to see you Jason I feel like mr. Rogers
with this sweater why you look great you
look great take your sling my neighbor
now talk about fish this guy let's talk
about your office for a second so if I
play this game tap-tap fish
I'm telling tell these people what's
going on in your office currently
currently right now nothing
it's an AB what I have two tanks filled
with dead weight is it true yeah oh man
I'm sorry to bring that up there was one
fish man I had an octopus in that right
guys right you smell great by the way
does that mean I smell terrible because
you smell awesome I don't smell anything
bad but you smell oh you smell great
mainland oh you oh you smell neutral I
smell so we're basically this is from
this way to this way good smelling too
terrible wait wait wait this is lansky
question yeah there's a lot of George so
when we go on travel shows chilling
means the guy sits a lot calm and Italy
of course we did it with Jordan and what
were some of your favorite parts about
that besides not being around Jordan
which food food Johnny B been to have
you been to Europe I've been a year yeah
I went to Spain oh my god how was Spain
it was great
I've never been to Spain I don't want we
go to Spain you should do it we should
go to Spain what did you do in Spain I
did some Spanish things I bullfight
which when write which seems like they
do well Bulls win they tell you the bull
can win if it doesn't well it's kind of
gruesome bull wins in Vernon exactly so
I think that's that's not a real thing
by the way that's that's like saying
does the Island of Hawaii ever win right
again in mulana right yeah Moana right
the Island of Hawaii wins in Moana
that's true but it was it wasn't the
pageantry was enjoyable I think you know
they could end there
with just them running around
as Lacroix the crowds are crazy they
rock this is crazy raucous crowd
shooting bottle rockets from their hands
like what soccer match says that's very
to the barian safe seems extremely
unsafe shooting bottle rockets from the
hands but that was great I've never been
to Italy I'd love to go yeah I mean have
you been Italy before that oh okay well
good lord Italian travel over here
wait this is the home stretch right this
is noon
all right goes till noon we've got a lot
of great guests including you guys I'm
wrapping up Pete I'm delirious wants to
know if this is Bill tall's brother and
finally how did you first get started
with the show uh-huh me I started as an
intern how long is this draw by the way
it looks like an ass for a longer straw
that's the best they can do is a
two-foot straw I started as an intern in
1996 intern for a year doesn't seem
right you winter for a year I was out of
college or any of you had 12 months you
were on a college that's not an
international interns and you enjoyed
career and you were an intern you just
hear you were just a person around I
hung around you just [ __ ] around and
then they got tired of me just staying
here not getting doing real work just
hung around hey guys no point were like
I was just in charge of the other
interns that's amazing it's 97 I
remember going down to the Christmas
party in December of 97 and I guys like
this job there if you want it
we've seen your pretty bossy with the
other interns there if you want plus
your bill tells brother about you shoes
so how many years is that since I've
been working or interning I've been
hired for 21 years in December
well December that's right huh so it's
20 years just really working every 20
years yeah it doesn't look good based on
how I look I look very young yeah
the Hat helps yeah you this beard though
has been huge you've let this beard good
and we had Roey on about 20,000 hours
ago we had Roane roie's beard is a mess
it's out of control
I think we can all agree every time my
mom sees any Roey
ever she's like would you please she
texts me and she says Rowi the beard I
was like I know I told man he doesn't
he's brush and love beards but he's
someone you want to grab and [ __ ] you
just want to take it and swing him
around every time the beard gets longer
he tightens up the sides yeah like
insane it's just gonna be he's gonna
become one of those like Easter Island
statues like in person just walk around
that's sure yeah he's just like it's a
mess oh wait croteau how did you get
started with the show I was also an
intern also did your 3 entrance on the
couch right here are you guys smelling -
worst smelling intern for seven years
[Laughter]
what was the hot do you guys remember
your entry was a highlight of your
internship cuz these kids now man
they don't understand I we I did crazy
things as an intern there's also more
interns now there's my way more I was an
intern it was like eight of us right and
it was also back in New York and it was
chaos
yes it was utter chaos back into your
home we had to turn our cell phones in
at the front desk at the beginning of
every day is that a real thing yeah
really
like this was nascent I use a typewriter
to write a get your write up contracts
and this is how I type so it took me a
really long time you had
your personal typewriter in with you I
had to hand my personals never at the
end of the beginning every day was
sucked I don't even know why I brought
it was like why am i bringing my temper
doesn't make any sense
all right we're gonna play a different
game right now this game's gonna be
called The Adventures of Bertram fiddle
all right I don't know what this is but
it's a dread Lee business episode 1 it's
a dread Lee business guys because I
figure this is kind of you know we're
kind of I I think all of us probably
amateur to tennis a Mary Poppins oh yeah
oh yeah we're kind of like amateur
detectives right three yes
yeah I'll salute this way yeah we're
gonna slip this one out who wants to
hold the thing that's not sure you know
what one thing that chills is great at
is trivia we got so far each cue yeah
well you but you got the last question
with this last question have you ever
played HQ court oh no I saw some people
suggest it's a it's pretty great you
know what it is you know it's a live
trivia thing happens twice a day what
yeah like noon and 6:00 and it's an app
you can find it on the Google Play Store
a million people plan over a million
people play starting today at the end
you know you windy and splitting the
money's at $1,200 and you split the
money with like 50 people yeah what's
the buys like 30 cents there's no
there's no button just your time in your
life life energy yeah it's the guys you
hit the alarm clock there yeah I'll put
it up
I can't wait to pair guys wait is that
thing on his front of his nose savage
Bolt wants to know if you consider
yourself friends with Jordan yes Oh used
to share an office with a word yeah
actually I have a great i7 when I was an
intern that so a quick story about
Shalini is
chills sharing opposite Jordan and my
sister weirdly for a while yes and they
used to have bits they had great bits
now the best bit of all time my favorite
bit can I explain this [ __ ] sure okay
I'll explain first of all what the
effect is then then what is so great I
come into this our pizza oh yeah yeah
but I guess now I'm saying it you're not
gonna be able to get anybody on the chat
with it and
also a may not be you still have it
Jordan's last storage Oz I can't believe
he has it cuz it's I work for the show
for 16 years this happened 15 years it's
discussing it's so gross yeah did you
ever get hit with this yeah okay so
basically I came in one day they called
me an inner rush in a panic and they're
like it's Nancy and slimy and you're
like they have a piece of pizza there
and they're like Blair Blair I'm holding
I'm holding
you're holding a slice of pizza like
Blair we need we I have to eat this
pizza have to in you're like desperate
like I'm so so hungry I'm starved Gotti
knows and say hey but you're hey what
was it with your hands your hands your
hands dirty hands you can see we're
about to ask him with you love that you
but you can't eat the pizza without it
being seasoned I can't eat me some
tonight yawns even if it's garlic
there's anybody have any garlic I need
and I was like I don't have and by the
way I'm like an intern you guys I'm like
what can I get you Carly Oh mr. Geelani
and then Jesse's like I have garlic over
here I have your pipes up hi I'm garlic
right here and I'm like oh great but he
also says my but my hands are dirty I
can't put the garlic on to the to my
wall can you Joe and I'm like wait I can
hey I don't wanna reach it to the girl
in 30 hits old thing and they called me
in Russian I'm like oh my god and
they're like we need you to put the
garlic on the pizza oh my god rush
around the thing in the office and I'm
like garbage and he's got the buddies
got there sorry got food hanging he's
got food and he's got the garlic over
there like he's shining beacon and then
schlemm he's holding the slice of pizza
he's so hungry starving it's like she
hated him he's dying
so I to go over there and he's like
saying take the garlic put on the beets
I'm like okay okay and I go over and as
soon as I touch the thing be mean Jordan
you scream out Bait but as I get loud be
wasn't expecting it why we need idols a
garlic anything and I like and but the
garlic is solidified yeah it looks like
it's powdery but it's hard
it's hard is a rock it's disgusting when
you got it's it's not food it's not even
food same inedible anymore it's just
like a maggot we just said this lab Bing
just makes me enjoy how'd you workshop
the sound oh I screamed I basically
filled my pants out of fear it was crazy
and then of course you call somebody
else did so that it's like you call
another person it's like so dirty I was
doing like a car worker so I was working
on a car and there you come in and
they're in a panic and then everybody's
screaming we got Emily koppenhaver so
good that's so good so silly oh my god
and he's and by the way Carly turn still
has to discuss her on the car it's so
nasty so already at that point the girls
different-colored I've been sitting at
so long and his desk and it solidified a
window so really it got hard and then
but it's traveled to LA it's crazy
[Laughter]
goblin library yeah Jordan still has the
garlic it's still there we still have oh
my god oh that was crazy and then there
was another one there's a Captain Jack
and Jack sighs that was like you walk
into the office and that only happened
at night and that one I saw all the
lights had to be dead yet yeah down and
so what would that one was because their
office looked right on - we were on the
ninth ninth floor on the west side it
looked right on the Radio City it was
and so it was lit up at night that glow
from red neon lights came through the
windows right it's my best ops I've ever
had was when I was like 20 to 30 rocker
and looked out over radio Jordan garlic
my first job in New York City same thing
I was 22 and had an office with this
great view
and one day I did not work for the show
yet no I saw someone on top of the
apartment building across the street
throw Kermit the Frog puppet off the top
of an apartment well I can recoup and
then I saw it on the show Muppets faces
of death of that you were there
our producer it was our building yeah I
was very scared to do that because we
didn't have any permission we just threw
scarring children man I think we have
bejeweled if you hate this do hate this
guy I don't hate it I just don't know
what's happened on could just play this
game I would love to see him playing
bejeweled blitz just cuz it's but I will
say it like give me like all those candy
games and children jewels which are for
adults but yeah you just have to match
three we're gonna we don't want to look
ahead and like so it so the biggest like
you've you match three that next to next
next three go down the next video
yeah yeah it's essentially like chess
but it's like brightly : my question is
what what's the difference between the
Blitz and the classic bejeweled well
they're constantly adding these little
powerup gems that you can use is ever
gonna be something that explodes the
whole screen or something that's
something it's written where the stuffs
not like slams door no but I was
explaining earlier that I I play this
game they made the Kermit met meme Mme
oh yeah na is the way I guess it's
curving it's a Kermit mean I guess
that's the Kerman mean we made it that's
cool
you made it well done me maker you lived
it you lived it yo Matthew have let your
glitch
what's that I I play this
in 30 seconds birds like on 40 minutes
nice yes exactly
red lights I'm in someone says it's
nothing like chess square type I think
garry kasparov plays this and chess yeah
Willy they're gonna I want to see I got
so I got that master class thing I want
to see chakra to do a master class on
this amazing okay
so we're playing a blue rocket thing and
it's sort of like searching for Bobby
Fischer and I you know the more sushi
for Bobby is the minimum that you can
get I love it so here's it's gotta be at
least three but you can get more than
three obviously yeah and if you get them
if you get five you turns into this
whole tornado I love the most I can
befall you fish I love by the way that's
a great movie I agree he's doing a move
and Laurence Fishburne's like there it
is so Laurence Fishburne at my Ralph's
oh really
shopping also what about Bobby Fischer
your fire is dying
that's totin yeah yeah yeah fire is
dying if anyone wants to play along with
me and purple yeah
this is adorable yours okay y'all this
is where comes Oh that we're getting I
have won the opportunity to choose now
this is getting and so we should write
someone choose
oh yeah let somebody Jim okay that's
adorable I always choose the same one
you always choose the same way yes and
it is always this one Wow oh no never
win because if one time in your Ines and
I don't choose it
my shirt will be going away it's like
it's like choosing lotto number again
you don't have real
it's right you win these are real coins
I have an account those are bellow I see
hunter says this is like bejeweled
michaelbay edition this is very intense
you see I need that in my life I it
takes a lot to get me going
something yeah that's good for like okay
you're gonna have so much fun yeah I
think it's you know it Celebi he's very
into sport we played Sparkle earlier now
is that you make Sparkle guy are you
your trivia guy are not real I love
trivia and I love Sparkle I feel like
let me introduced me to it ten years ago
in New York oh yes the first one was
that I remember was trying to fill in
states like you'd have an empty map oh
yeah oh speaking of states here's
something super nerdy we used to play
remember online risk a little marker
club what yeah no there's nothing dirty
about it
yeah online risk I remember being we
would we would play these tournaments
and I remember being like in Mexico with
my family and like calling like Chile
being like okay man whatever moves yeah
because you have to do it every 24 hour
like my family is like what are you
doing how I got a train schedule trip
sir I'm not good hey Starkiller oh good
evening from London there we go
by the way Starkiller there's a pub in
London or Gandalf plays trivia ian
mckellen runs a trivia night every
Monday ask Anna no I think it's a sorry
so we have the pickup thing here okay
someone give me a number one two three
four five six seven eight nine choose
wisely the first number that comes up
I'm kidding what's your rank bro Oh what
is my rank what our ranks a couple go
ahead I don't remember
who's with you guys that is no joke
after years that is the first time I
thought I'd say this it's never okay
claps I can't I can't believe that
happened I would have had so many Jews
never seen a man's heartbreak in person
that was incredible there goes the
leader Wow oh my god Wow oh my god that
was gnarly
everyone I don't run right I want to get
back in the cockpit club I want to do it
it's fun man we had such great
strategies like I know where it why it
was my first experience with trolls
someone was losing okay being immature
someone was losing and they basically
losing reported me to the mother-in-law
that's the word that I had a block and
then there already be things that I was
like this isn't yeah safe space that was
the last time I play safe space you can
stay in the landmark in it's a
historical in the rumor that Amelia
Earhart stayed there a few times I will
say if you want to ever get Conan to do
anything appeal to his historical sense
yeah that is the way to do it all you
need to say is like hey this Kurt you
know like Hemingway sat on this curb
peevly so you guys miss playing this
game about paying attention you guys are
gonna go to the Bermuda Triangle yo man
I would love to get you don't wait did
you hear that they actually figured out
what the Bermuda Triangle thing was it's
like I trapped a bunch of gas that like
comes up out of the sea
did you guys hear about that so it just
rips hair
yeah blow and sinks oh no and no it's
sink ships because it's like a bubbly
it's like air pockets for some reason in
that part of the world I'm totally
having deja vu right now and I might be
having a stroke you are crazy but like
air pockets bubble up from beneath
another water and and like micro bubbles
and sink ships
huh you know what else six ships loose
lips it's like you know remember the
Olympics when they had those little
bubbles and everybody who is breaking
all those breaking all those records and
they said it because the bubbles broke
up in the water yeah like that on a
larger scale happens in the Bream a try
back me up chat back media where people
sinking it yes no they were so what said
three so much still hearing the music
from flipping Ledger's good look six
would have been the last Louis to me
yeah there we go
alright so you know why you're branching
out I think that's a good thing
wrench down a little bit oh oh my god
alright here we go
I haven't been paying attention what do
I need to do here yeah I got a really
high score I got the new high score wait
what do I need to do just match all
three it's sort of like Kenny's a time I
never like that this time
it runs out on you do I want to equip
this mystery boost sure what is that I'm
worried about this mystery I don't like
mysteries I like things that are okay
okay you did that very quickly you're
gonna prep oh I just need to go for it
oh I'm sitting right now and the way you
guys are sitting yeah it's like you're
giants and I'm just like oh yeah I like
that alright let's see is it just three
or can it be more than three you want it
to be more than three if you get five
you get a rare gem that five okay that
will get every color going oh my god is
it have to be in a line it vertical or
horizontal
we're they're dying oh dang or they can
be L shape yeah yeah that's Jess
now this one the Purple's our bishops
and they can only go diagonal okay got
it
what do you mean the gosh how's it
calling you to play with my emotions
curriculum which seemed weird that seems
like an American like its castling like
it seems that the room looks like a
cat's what's a tower right yeah there's
a castle yeah there we go
Rob ie I like done look at us I think
you're trying to get us to say a fake
names I love that I do love that that is
my favorite thing how do we do how do we
do well time's up I don't think I did
very well
Jamie's Packard is hiding in the
bathroom Network to watch this yes James
Packard is too beautiful yeah what
oh thanks gay you know I see beautiful
for something else having oh we gotta
play something else shall we yeah let's
play something else
we don't have to let mean you tell me no
yeah he's learning the next the jewel is
uh-oh
it's what the best thank you so my
favorite riff jason said he enters every
room that I'm ever in you know we could
play that seemed so I say chills you
just walk in ready to go
yeah see no one but I know I'm gonna be
surprised he's known you for 20 years
yeah everyone knows who you are yeah
okay so I just unlocked this gem I'm
gonna move it green also gets all the
drinks so all the greens so whatever one
you hit what am I call the code huh and
I just made like a little triangle one
Oh what color do you want it has the
most yeah exactly
I think it's red or purple red it is and
you know purple is just red and black
my favorite my favorite chill bent aside
from hard garlic which is obviously a
classic there's two one is this is
actually a kind of a rare bit you see
this is Sharon Hardy
are you coming around the desk you come
around be like you smell that oh my god
you submit yeah and then what would you
do
and by the way Hardy would be like in
the middle of a phone call she's
sweating and like trying to get like the
rights for some video it wasn't burning
yeah nothing was burning up it's nothing
but she what she was doing she could
have been talking to like the president
yeah exactly you know recently someone
big or sometime in the show uh give me
some bad LL Cool J LL Cool J annual dad
talking to you know head producers doing
l ago Jake yeah researching I suppose
smell like what do you think what
immediately was your like phone down
yeah the shoulder carry her right man
carrier out of the room she's on the
phone with LL Cool J but I saved it
every time every time he's saved so what
happened more than once
oh yeah she never had a choice she never
said what it was never like no there's
nothing reduced every single time there
was something burned he'd be like oh my
god and would hang up the phone yeah
cause less important than its life yeah
dude exactly this is just you know you
got everyone else in the room burned
I always saved Hardy yeah never saved me
by the way i watch it all go down every
time I would try to be like don't fall
is it just because she's petite she was
easier to live yeah yeah let's play a
different game ready yeah we're gonna
play a game called Sonic - yeah you know
a well oh we got a sonic here I don't
know how to play oh it seems like it's
loaded on what this is
I'm gonna run in place maybe tapping do
you tap out oh yeah it's a it's a thing
oh there seems like it's like that game
other game the Temple Run yeah yeah
every temple run does seem it's a temple
run and paired it with one of our
favorite characters
it's like song - 100
that's this looks dangerous yeah I will
say some of the most the worst moments
of my childhood involved playing Sonic
and I have like 10,000 gold rings and
when you get hit a coach crabs crabs I
grew up knowing Nintendo and we thought
Sega was for like weird rich people who
lived on the coast yeah I think you know
you come from working plumbing folk yeah
like the Mario Brothers that's right
what is this it's just fantastic
yeah he spends his whole day running
around stuff he's never picked up a
wrench but an honest day's work can you
be knuckles I don't know if you can oh
goblin library just got into a temper
run again that's a good game but
geometry - maybe we will Knights of the
Old Republic I don't know if we're gonna
I did they I think we played that I
think Erik and Kent played that we had
Eric and Kent in here yeah they did the
we the bad guy
Eggman whoa you got your Eggman so wait
how many games are under the play
ah like a billion I'm not sure how many
games sorry seems like every gamer
they're all there seems like no matter
what game you mentioned it's here that's
true it's it's amazing Google play's
incredible and we played I think we
played upwards of like 28 29 games
already am I putting or is this like
when I go to the arcade and I don't have
a corner no I think this is I think
you're actually playing right you gotta
pay enough we're keep running and I'll
give me four dollars appeasing it says
just be four dollars for box pursue it I
give you the money yeah just give it
give it to him and then he'll yeah he'll
video games are so advanced we're all
you know we're all I gotta say we're
almost seven more minutes I got it
before we go I have to say my one of my
favorite slimming bits of all time is a
thing
very few period have you ever done it in
lost a there's only once I think the
cave hasn't happen to know the cave
hasn't happened in a long time it's more
something gross than a bit I think yeah
the cave is yeah he basically sneaks up
behind people and just less than into my
said yeah comments covers and covers her
face with a shirt it's the cake
that's that person's head is near my
belly yeah again the last person has
happened to Sharon harsher words here in
a long time
seems like she allowed a lot of things
yes she said yes to a lot of things well
but I forgot to talk about Captain Jack
that's my other favorite pastime Frank's
good so it but Captain Jack only have a
bad job my [ __ ] this is also a mulch
Lansky yeah this was such like this was
more of a shlonsky bit well who started
the bit was it De Luca it was more we
just I think it was um De Luca I just
play music right boys they would call
right they would call again they would
call you in or me and I was like Anna
you know we tested everything I never
tested everything yeah very gullible
because I wanted a I was eager to please
yes
as a young buck yeah you know I'm there
for you I'm ready to go whatever you
need I'm here and so they're like we
need you in our office I'm like oh my
god and this is by the way after I got
burned by hard garlic so I should have
known Sunday yeah you guys never need
anything ever you need anything yeah
what did you ever get immediately never
nothing nothing where their hands dirty
it's so dirty and so I would ran into
the I remember this that literally
someone would come in the other person
would go close the doors almost are
killing us from Bronx dead now you can't
leave like it was like yeah it closed
the door yes lights turned off no lights
were off it was one of those like
halogen like yeah yeah so you would what
I ran in it was on the only light was
from the neon glow
he's very blade runner running you're
like huh huh and then the door shuts
behind you and then immediate
I would hit the button stereos yeah from
the beginning of Captain Jack can't
afford it okay yeah so that little piano
medley this is Billy Joel and then the
only thing you see is chill Emmy a
silhouetted in the light standing with
his back to you it was like right it was
yeah
no no you were down you were down down
and then Jordan is hiding behind the
door with a halogen light and then
there's a partner that goes blue
dudududududu but I mean you wouldn't put
the halogen light and then he would do
this thing ridiculous like Michael
Jackson yeah
how about three times in a row and
you're like okay this is it
yeah is this mainly made yeah me Jordan
nothing else at that point you're just
in there for the show and the engineer
might has a long song it's a really long
time 12 again it's a long song and
you're in there for a while and he's
doing the thing and Jordans got the
light going I mean it was a whole every
crime in Jordan remote when he says to
Conan I'm various duties do captain
Webber garlic yeah and hard garlic that
is one of Jordan's duties as Harry's
garlic good at his dude you know what he
is pretty good tiger yeah I agree with
that a free good both good at their
duties so many bits so many so many
great bits what are our bits now we
don't have a lot of bits now yeah well
you have that was Michael Stipe you owe
Michael Stipe dressed as Steve Zissou
[Laughter]
mashup for the ages that's a yeah I
agree
that's that is uh that's incredible um
all right yeah I think I mean we have
three more minutes but don't you want to
play one more around a sonnet I think
you could do it well I was recently
listening you to I keep going back to
New York but you know ii did so much
work on the website
there and a lot of people don't know
that we actually started the website
because we did a newsletter in the
office right that's why that's actually
how I got into the web thing the LNG
yeah yeah man laid eggs at a monthly
newsletter and retaining that name was
involved yeah we horse go the staff it
was a a comic strip Hosea I did a little
Conan comic strip we got to bring that
back oh yeah that was amazing we should
put those online they were great they
were really Conan as a child and they
were really funny but it was like
headlight it would be like headline news
like it was just like you know well the
headline news was it was monthly so
again you just name one no but there was
a huge I mean I think the biggest debate
was what sodas should be stocked soda
machine no that was also like like you
know send your letters into the editor
kind of a thing like what do you want to
see they the end the last page was
always like photos of the staff as
children child
oh right match them and guess who is I
have them all by the way we could break
these now oh yeah we definitely good and
then we did yeah we we do horoscopes
well see oh and then we do rumors along
the bottom mm-hmm like blind items
tidbits yeah in a quote him Danno
a quote of data blind quotes maybe like
be like one staff you know one staff
member at trivia was heard saying dead
edited a you know like that kind of a
thing it was really stressful it's in
our head like oh it has to be out of a
certain area like and we were like okay
now headed me on this special paper that
always made the copier jam for some
reason and it was really it was anything
like all the President's Men like we had
to put this out it was like that every
every month it was like all the
President's Men every month we had
secrets that that the world needed to
know
and the world is like 50 people on our
side yeah basically they didn't really
floor of whom with
now we can do it digitally oh yeah that
was crazy same paper save a lot of paper
we could have yeah a lot but the kids
today man they don't know you know they
don't care about blind items and what's
going on yeah well you know one article
that got a lot of traction was rusyn
Annie and thinking that the water was
being poisoned because it was in plastic
oh that's shoe we had a big debate about
plastic bottles and water in the office
that's a good thing though yeah I don't
know if she was I think like she was the
person who found that I found that out
that was amazing
no I'm alright I think it guys she wants
us to wrap really this my name is oz
it's not a clock thank you - Jason
that's right now this finish it off
marry it off let's check in with mr.
Conan O'Brien right now everybody right
it's 9 o'clock I know buddy you brush
your teeth before 9:00
I don't you wait I don't want to brush
my teeth and then that breakfast it also
kills the taste of coffee so I
traditionally brush my teeth after
breakfast
that's another little fun fact for you
I'm using a reach toothbrush alright the
reach
this saves on water that's a
conservation tip so I'll see you again
at ten that's what we done brushing my
teeth by then I really work the gums you
got to work the gums or else they recede
and you get that look that look that
some people have their teeth are like
tombstones stuff to their face everybody
welcome back to the 24-hour mobile
marathon sponsored by google play let me
shut up oh hello Lisa Burnham everybody
and where she got married her name is
Lisa Blair cuz she's my sister
can they don't understand how siblings
work and last names and how two people
can have the last name I see something
you have great hair you die this well
you can dye your hair I can't
it doesn't take color that well yeah all
right
this is look I know you get a plug for
your L'Oreal products they want to send
me some and rv6
know smartest person coming on the
stream first person in 20 however many
hours to try to get free stuff I mean I
have two kids I can't buy anything yeah
exactly this is a Blair right here
that's right trying to work the system
trying to what do you think about this
shirt just like politically incorrect
when you start with when you start with
and then followed up with I like it
that's an I think like booties those are
pretty are they on trends you're an
adult why do you call your shoes booties
well because they don't go all the way
up there just boots but they're just
their booties no booties are something a
child wears that's true Thanks these are
boots you're a grown woman but they're
not long what are long boots called that
I there's caboose
so those are boots these are booties and
what are the like booze yeah maybe just
no they're called shoes that called
booster called shoes and fell right into
my track right in my truck all right
guys Oh
we are in the homestretch it is
according to my calculations 903 my
calculations I mean the clock I just
looked at we got 2 hours and 56 minutes
53 seconds we got some more special
guests coming up we got a an amazing
exclusive musical performance coming up
right now in case your stream is going
down we are cycling we're not likely the
thing we're gonna say we're gonna cut to
the tape right now right instead perfect
all right instead of recycling the
stream we are going to hey marshmallow
crew woot bleh thanks a lot you know
what you're ruining both of us cuz we're
both up top we were gonna go to we're
gonna watch this amazing exclusive
musical performance by none other Margot
Price who was on our show and did this
special song just for us which means
just for you it's called do right by me
and here it is enjoy
[Applause]
[Music]
baby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah way so the lap down
[Music]
let her tell their you're not fat the
bottom spending all the precious time on
money flame starter was my own song say
myself a baby
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
hey everybody welcome back to 24-hour
mobile marathon spots my Google Play
we're here with my sister what's up guys
Lisa berm formally the lease alert
I tell people what you do on the show
will introduce yourself properly Lisa
and well I like to be friendly
hashtag that so Lisa I am the audience
coordinator so I coordinate the the
shoes oh that's right hands
I booked all the tickets right like pass
out I called the ambulance wrestle cats